et donc nous recevons aujourd'hui
monsieur le Président directeur général
de Total énergie Patrick puyenné donc je
rappelle dans le cadre de cette mission
que nous allons donner la parole pour
les questions qui suivront aux membres
de la mission d'information je prie
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
des finances qui assistent de bien
vouloir nous excuser mais c'est la règle
qu'on s'est imposée pour les différentes
auditions afin de permettre d'avoir les
échanges les plus riches possibles nous
donneront aussi la parole s'il le
souhaite à monsieur le Président de la
Commission et monsieur le rapporteur
général du budget donc nous avons
beaucoup de questions évidemment à vous
adresser monsieur le Président Directeur
Général sur cette question des profits
exceptionnels à la fois d'ailleurs sur
la manière dont on les caractérise leur
montant leur provenance à la fois leur
géographiques et par type d'activités
sont-ils amenés à durer ou non selon les
différentes estimations qu'on peut faire
des évolutions du marché du pétrole du
gaz et plus généralement de l'énergie
dans les années à venir quel usage en
effet où est-il prévu d'en faire
là aussi ça nous paraît être une
question extrêmement importante à la
fois en termes de gestes en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat que ce soit d'ailleurs
des Français ou de vos propres salariés
mais aussi en termes d'investissement
particulièrement dans la transition
écologique nous aurons aussi l'occasion
d'aborder les questions fiscales à la
fois les montants
d'impôts de cotisations que vous équipez
d'ores et déjà et puis les différentes
pistes d'évolution qui peuvent être
débattues au niveau national le coréen
nous avons donc beaucoup de sujets à
discuter ce que je vous propose c'est
peut-être de faire un propos introductif
d'environ cinq minutes ce qui permettra
ensuite de passer aux questions je vous
souhaite la parole
bonjour bonjour monsieur le rapporteurs
monsieur le Président Monsieur mesdames
et messieurs les députés
merci de m'accueillir aujourd'hui pour
répondre directement à vos questions
j'ai d'ailleurs pris la décision et je
m'en excuse auprès de Monsieur bourlant
puisque je devais être auditionné ce
matin par deux commissions de vous
donner plus de temps à celle là qui
avait un je dirais un calendrier urgent
et je remercie de Monsieur bourge je
dirais devant la commission des affaires
étrangères sans doute au mois de
novembre mais je ne pouvais pas dans la
même matinée faire les deux de façon je
dirais correcte à répondre à toutes vos
questions bon je voulais juste sur le
sujet fiscal rappelé un centre
d'éléments juste pour cadrer l'exercice
de mon point de vue et puis après je
répondrai à toutes vos questions et je
suis animé dans ce matin dans un esprit
de totalement transparence nous n'avons
rien à cacher sur ces matières là et
nous sommes d'ailleurs à l'origine du
premier rapport de transparent fiscal
qui est paru en début d'année en mars
2022 pour leur on avance sur tous les
débats qu'on appelle laisser BCR que
nous avons utilisé largement au-delà du
périmètre européen pour vous y trouverez
dans ce document
les 80 pays dans lesquels nous
produisons du pétrole donc on a étendu
le périmètre de façon à être le plus
large ça coûte 80% de notre chiffre
d'affaires et donc en les métiers
d'ordre c'est soyons transparent donc je
vais rappeler simplement d'abord je vous
rappelle que nous payons bien évidemment
des impôts sur les bénéfices mais dans
les pays où nous réalisons des bénéfices
c'est un principe de territorialité qui
est un principe de non double imposition
qui fixe le droit international de la
fiscalité l'entreprise comme la mienne
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que c'est un principe qui est reconnu
d'entre très nombreux pays bien
évidemment par la France qui a signé le
très nombreuses conventions fiscales
internationales fondamentalement un même
profit ne peut pas être imposé deux fois
il y a deux grands types de régimes
fiscaux aujourd'hui il y a des régimes
fondés sur la territorialité qui prévoit
que les profits réalisés dans le pays
sont imposables dans ce pays-là c'est le
régime d'ailleurs français puis il y a
des régimes dans notre pays qui sont dit
mondiaux où on prend cette accession
dans le pays de la maison-mère des
profits de l'ensemble des filiales de la
maison mère mais tous ces régimes là
prévoient la non double imposition
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'on fait une base
mondiale on déduit de l'impôt qui se
réduit par la Maison Verte les impôts
déjà payés à l'étranger voilà les deux
grands régimes on a d'ailleurs été
soumis dans notre histoire de 2000 à
2011 par le fameux bénéfice mondial
consolidé à ce régime dit mondial on a
fait j'ai fait refaire les calculs pour
voir s'il y aurait une différence on
aurait payé exactement la même chose en
France dans sur la période 2000 2010 si
on avait été sur une base mondiale ou
sur une base française parce qu'encore
une fois profondément nous faisons des
bénéfices dans la plupart de nos pays où
nous produisons du pétrole et du gaz et
donc ces bénéfices et ses impôts que
nous aurions Pella aurait été déduits de
la base d'imposition française
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que nous payons des
impôts pour ceux qui et notamment dans
le monde je voulais juste rappeler trois
chiffres en 2020 avec le covid les prix
c'était effondrés nous payons
mondialement c'est l'année la plus basse
6 milliards de divers impôts sur les
bénéfices et taxe à la production c'est
mondiale en 2021 nous en avons payé 16
milliards
8 milliards d'impôts sur les bénéfices 8
milliards de taxes à la production en
2022 nous paierons 30 milliards d'impôts
et de taxes à la production mondialement
30 milliards de dollars je parle en
dollars décidément il se trouve qu'en ce
moment le dollar et l'euro sont pareils
30 milliards pourquoi parce que dans la
grande majorité des pays producteurs où
nous sommes implantés la fiscalité
s'adapte avec les prix du pétrole donc
en fait la rente pétrolière ou gazières
et capter par les pays où nous
exploitons les ressources naturelles ou
les produisons et et donc c'est là que
nous payons l'immense majorité de ces
impôts sur les sociétés et c'est axe à
la pollution qui correspond bien au
principe mondial de territorialité dont
je vous ai parlé ça c'est pour les
niveaux mondial alors maintenant j'en
viens à la France qui vient évidemment
vous intéresse alors en France les
activités que nous avons ne sont pas du
tout les activités de rente pétrolières
nous avons des activités de marge nous
avons le tactile notamment de raffinage
le raffinage commence à marcher c'est
assez simple alors affinage achète du au
prix mondial du pétrole c'est les règles
que nous imposons évidemment mondial qui
sont tous les prix de transferts sont
les cotations mondiales et puis on
raffine ce pétrole pour en faire de
l'essence du diesel du kérosène on a des
cotations sur les marchés européens pour
les raffineries françaises puisque c'est
les marchés de Rotterdam qui sont les
marchés directeurs ont fait la
différence entre les cotations ce qu'on
produit et notre prix du pétrole et puis
on enlève des coûts fixes le résultat de
tout ça c'est qu'en fait le raffinage
français est en perte assez
régulièrement parce que pourquoi parce
que profondément le marché européen de
l'essence du diesel est en baisse qu'il
y a des surcapacités de raffinage au
niveau européen et que on se retrouve
avec un business raffinage qui en fait
profondément et ben les revenus que nous
en dirons la marche sur coût variable
que nous tirons ces différences entre
les ventes de produits raffinés et
l'achat de pétrole brut n'est pas
rentable ou ne permet pas de découvrir
les coûts fixes alors plus concrètement
pour que les choses soient claires j'ai
on a répondu à un questionnaire assez
complet d'ailleurs que le messieurs les
rapporteurs nous ont adressés
on est au fil depuis 2021 quand on
regarde les bases fiscales depuis je
réservé les traits 2013 à 21 les 26
cales françaises en fait
sur la période on a à peu près on a des
pertes reportables aujourd'hui de 5,3
milliards d'euros donc 4,3 milliards
d'euros viennent du raffinage français
je vous donner la série de chiffres
c'est pas très brillant en 2013 nous
avons perdu fiscalement - 840 millions
d'euros en 2014 - 1 milliard 4 en 2015 -
300 en 2016 et de 2017 on a fait des
profits de 150 et 400 millions en 18 -
300 en 2019 moins 200 en 2020 année
noire du covid - 1 milliard et demi et
en 2021 moins de 140 alors effectivement
cette année nous allons continuer que
les marches de raffinage à cause du
d'ailleurs des en partie de du fait que
de la décision des
pays européens de faire un ban de bannir
les produits russes c'est avant le
disait russe les cotations ont remonté
donc nous allons gagner de l'argent mais
alors ça ne couvrira loin s'en fout les
pertes que nous avons faites puisque
notre marge au cours du premier semestre
en France en moyenne est à peu près de
euros la tonne donc on devrait faire un
résultat sur l'année de l'ordre dans le
raffinage j'imagine de l'ordre de 600
millions d'euros autour de faire pour
par ailleurs en France nous n'avons pas
que cette activité je vous rappelle que
nous avons des activités également de
distribution de gaz et d'électricité ou
le blocage et le bouclier tarifaire se
traduit dans des entreprises comme la
nôtre par des par des pertes
relativement importantes donc voilà la
situation que dans laquelle nous le
savoir en France au-delà de l'impôt sur
les sociétés qui attirent beaucoup
l'attention l'entreprise et fournisseurs
de taxes diverses et en fait et de non
seulement de taxes sociales enfin de
cotisations sociales pardon pour à peu
près 1 milliard d'euros par an puisque
nous avons 35000 salariés en France mais
également d'autres taxes qui
représentent en gros entre 600 et 1
milliard d'euros par an et notamment il
y a une taxe qui est ce que les gens
enfin une retenue à la source sur les
dividendes pour tous les actionnaires
étrangers de toute énergie qui sont
nombreux ça représente à peu près 500
millions d'euros par an c'est d'ailleurs
parce que notre siège est en France que
nous payons ces 500 millions d'euros
notre siège comme nos concurrents
seraient dans d'autres pays qui n'ont
pas à ce type de retenue à la source
c'est 500 millions d'euros sur la donc
la contribution entre je dirais
cotisation sociale taxe à la production
et notamment cette retenue à la source
sur les dividendes représentent en gros
de l'ordre de 1,6 à 9 milliards d'euros
par an de contribution
à
au budget français
autre point je vais parler transparence
alors un point que vous aviez souligné
qu'est-ce que nous faisons de nos
profits qui sont effectivement plus
importants cette année la première
priorité que nous avons puisque vous
avez vu que Total est devenu total
énergie qui se traduit profondément par
une évolution de notre stratégie puisque
d'un business model qui était centré sur
pétrole et gaz nous avons décidé de
rentrer dans la troisième énergie qui
est l'électricité et notamment à partir
d'énergie renouvelable et de façon
massive puisque notre ambition est
d'être d'ici la fin de la décennie dans
les cinq premiers mondiaux de premier
producteur mondiaux d'énergie
renouvelable nous avons fortement
accéléré puisque nous sommes passés de
2019 où nous investissions dans les
énergies gérer des carbonées un peu
moins d'un milliard nous situons à plus
3 milliards l'année dernière nous sommes
rend à 4 milliards cette année et compte
tenu du fait que en ce moment nous avons
je dirais luiition d'un contexte plus
favorable nous allons pouvoir accélérer
cette transition en augmentant
globalement nos investissements dont
seulement en valeur absolue mais
également au code-park puisque nous
allons viser à peu près qu'un tiers nous
investissements aille dans les énergies
des carbulées donc il y a une notamment
pour construire
je dirais une entreprise un bras de
production des production et de
distribution d'électricité qui soit
important à l'échelle mondial voilà
alors bien évidemment nos bénéfices il
n'y a pas que l'investissement
d'entreprise il y a également nos
salariés et
ça relève du dialogue social j'ai reçu
les organisations représentatives via la
semaine dernière mais bien évidemment
elles pourront bénéficier elles aussi de
la je dirais de la prospérité qui est
générée en ce moment par l'entreprise
sachant que les années comme les années
du covid on avait dû prendre des mesures
plus difficiles donc il faut qu'on
équilibrera et elles sont bien
évidemment au premier point de nos
préoccupations et nous utiliserons sans
doute les dispositifs votés par
l'Assemblée nationale de sont
relativement larges mais c'est encore
une fois cela relève du dialogue social
voilà ce que je peux dire en
introduction je suis bien évidemment
prêt à répondre à vos questions
merci merci pour ces introduction merci
de vous êtes rendu disponible pour cette
audition je vais vous poser les
premières questions bon l'objectif de
notre mission c'est de de regarder sur
les secteurs qui sont concernés par le
périmètre de l'émission s'il existe
effectivement des profits exceptionnels
et de savoir si il faut mettre en place
des dispositifs pour les pour les taxer
en France de ce point de vue là dans le
questionnaire que vous nous avez
transmis les réponses que vous avez
transmis les chiffres de vos résultats à
l'échelle mondiaux sont indiquées et sur
le premier semestre 2022 on se rend
compte que le résultat que a réalisé
l'entreprise que vous dirigez sur un
semestre et à peu près l'équivalent de
la moyenne qu'il était réalisé entre
2017 et 2019 je mets l'année 2020 de
côté parce qu'on sait que c'est une
année qui a été une année particulière
logiquement la question que notre
mission doit se poser c'est de savoir si
dans ces résultats une partie la source
de ces résultats provient du territoire
national même si les bénéfices eux sont
réalisés ou déclarés en tout cas dans
d'autres pays ça m'amène à deux
questions la première question
c'est la question sur les marges de
raffinage puisque vous avez dit le
raffinage c'est une activité dans les
marges sont importantes c'est ce que
vous rappelez dans la réponse au
questionnaire mais vous dites en quelque
sorte les raffineries françaises elles
sont peu utilisées vous avancez le
chiffre de 62 % dans l'utilisation des
capacités françaises et dans votre
propre introductive vous nous dites
c'est parce que le marché européen sur
les raffineries en quelque sorte il est
un peu saturé pourtant dans le même
questionnaire vous nous dites que c'est
62% les capacités d'utilisation en
France et que c'est 89% pour les autres
raffineries européennes donc je me
permets de poser la question pourquoi
cette différence et pour dire les choses
franchement on pourrait se poser la
question de savoir
s'il y a pas de manière un peu
volontaire une sous-utilisation des
raffineries françaises pour pouvoir
sortir un certain nombre de profits qui
afin qu'ils soient réalisés dans
d'autres pays que la France c'est une
question qu'on pourrait se poser donc je
aurai besoin de votre réponse sur le
sujet deuxièmement dans la même logique
on peut se poser la question de savoir
si du point de vue de votre politique de
ce qu'on appelle des prix de transfert
il y aurait pas là une manière aussi de
faire en sorte que des bénéfices qui
correspondent en vérité à une activité
qui a lieu sur le territoire en France
en réalité soit déclaré dans d'autres
pays donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser d'un point de vue de politique
de prix de transfert à part les les
échanges de produits d'une filiale à
l'autre quels sont les autres activités
qui correspondent à des prix de
transfert entre les différentes filiales
de votre groupe et notamment est-ce que
vous pouvez détailler de quoi il s'agit
en matière de recherche et développement
en matière d'expertise etc pour qu'on y
voit plus clair enfin troisième et
dernière question et je m'arrête là
question que vous avez pas abordé pour
l'instant
ça m'intéresserait d'avoir des
informations sur l'impact de la remise
extraordinaire ou exceptionnelle que
vous avez mis en place de manière
unilatérale et notamment de savoir si
oui ou non comme semble le dire à un
certain nombre de personnes dans la
presse ça s'est traduit pour vous par
une augmentation de vos ventes des
chiffres de 20% ont été avancés et de
savoir si vous confirmez ces chiffres si
effectivement cette remise s'est
traduise c'est traduite par une
augmentation de vos ventes voilà je vous
remercie
le premier point
Eddy en ce moment les marges de
raffinage sont positives donc on a tout
intérêt à faire marcher toutes nos
raffineries y compris les raffineries
françaises bon il se trouve que ce sont
deux pour cent a été impacté par deux
événements on a une raffinerie en
Normandie qui avait eu un accident qui a
mis du temps à redémarrer maintenant
elle tourne à fond et par ailleurs on
avait la raffinerie de Donges qui
faisait des pertes importantes qu'on
avait décidé d'arrêter au moment du
covid et qu'on a redémarré au mois
d'avril donc ce chiffre aujourd'hui de
62% sur le premier semestre est revenu à
80% ces outils là pour profondément il
faut les faire tourner au maximum donc
il y a aucune politique délibérée contre
la France surtout qu'en ce moment on a
un marché qui est porteur donc je veux
dire on est autant des arbitrages ont pu
être fait et notamment sur la raffinerie
Donges au moment du covid puisque chaque
chaque litre d'essence ou diesel qu'on
produisait se traduisait par des pertes
au passage je rappelle que pendant la
période du covid le groupe Total énergie
n'a demandé aucun soutien à l'état
français aucun soutien ils sont vraiment
des rares groupes français à avoir dit
non nous ne voulons aucun soutien malgré
des pertes extrêmement importantes comme
je viens de le dire sur nos activités
françaises je considérais que c'était
totalement responsive que de la part
d'un groupe comme le nôtre on doit être
capable de traverser des périodes
difficiles de façon à faire face à ces
difficultés de chômage partiel vous êtes
non nous n'avons pas bénéficié de
chômage partiel vous pouvez le vérifier
euro par Euro les quelques
usines qui avaient demandé à le faire
nous avons rendu moi nous-même tous les
euros à l'état puisque au premier mois
et donc il n'y a eu aucun dispositif
dans le total énergie à bénéficier en
France en 2020 j'y éveillé
personnellement
le deuxième question vous me posez les
prix transferts les prises transfert
c'est des mythes d'abord je veux dire
c'est un sujet vous aurez accès sans
aucun doute au dossier fiscaux totaux de
Total énergie qui est extrêmement suivie
en fait il y a un principe simple les
prix de transfert se font dans nos
métiers sur la base des cotations
internationales des produits qui vont
d'un pas d'un pays à un autre donc
lorsque je produis du pétrole en Angola
ce pétrole est vendu
aux activités trading de Total énergie
au prix international du pétrole et donc
l'Angola va me taxer sur le prix du
pétrole moins le coût de production
c'est là qu'il y a une rente et puis
lorsque je viens en France faire du
raffinage je vais acheter du pétrole
au prix international et je vais vendre
mes essences et mon diesel au prix
international ça c'est les règles de
base les règles qui sont mondialement
admises tout le système du fiscalité
mondiale fonctionne comme ça et il est
suivi alors après vous soulevez des
questions qui est en quoi des coûts de
holding ou là la maison mère et les
activités de recherche que nous
localisons à peu près à 50% en France à
peu près la moitié des chercheurs total
énergie en France comment nous
refacturons à nos filiales l'Angola par
exemple qui bénéficient du fait qu'il y
a des savoir-faire chaque année et ça
aussi nous y veillons et c'est aussi
suivi nous refacturons à peu près 2
milliards d'euros des services
techniques ou du service de personnel de
la France aux diverses filiales du
groupe international ce sujet est suivi
de très près par dans le cas d'ailleurs
d'une convention transparence fiscale
j'ai à côté j'ai diminué avec moi ma
directrice fiscale que j'aurais dû
présenter Nathalie monnetti qui je suis
attrapé et donc oui nous refacturons des
services
et de ce monde et elles sont de
convention qui sont prévues et
d'ailleurs c'est tout à fait notre
intérêt puisque dans la plupart de ces
pays total énergie n'est pas tout seul
je suis en partenariat avec d'autres
compagnies internationales donc c'est un
moyen pour nous de refacturer à son de
partenaires internationaux une partie de
nos coûts nous avons tout intérêt à ce
que cette mécanique de reversement de
déversement je dirais des coûts centraux
vers nos filiales ce qui se faire et non
seulement c'est suivi par les
commissaires aux comptes il y a des
audits qui sont faits tous ces prises
transfert et après le fils français il
passe du temps donc je sais que on peut
nous dire que on pourrait qu'il y a pas
de manipulation en une façon de ces prix
transfert ça suit les règles
internationales qui sont qui sont
connues transparentes et sur lesquels
Nathalie moïetti pourra vous éclairer
plus avant mais je vous en ai je vous en
ai donné les principes essentiels alors
maintenant l'opération de rabais bon
d'abord je voudrais dire que on avait
commencé dès le mois de mars je veux
dire avant même le débat qui a pu avoir
lieu au Parlement de juillet on avait
pris l'initiative dès le mois de mars de
nous-mêmes voyons bien que le prix de
l'essence notamment monté haute de faire
un effort directement on avait décidé
que les stations rurales françaises
bénéfhéraient serré d'un rabais de 10
centimes on l'avait étendu à plus de
stations au mois de mai puis on est allé
vers les stations autoroutières cet été
tout ça a représenté avec 10 centimes
d'ailleurs on a vu que nos concurrents
la plupart nous suivaient c'est-à-dire
que 10 centimes sur les autoroutes cet
été j'ai vu qu'il y avait un effet
d'entraînement sur pas mal de
concurrents qui nous ont suivis alors ça
c'est traduit par des volumes un peu
plus importants une vingtaine de % de
volume qui sont venus chez nous et donc
c'est une opération qui a coûté gérer
sur les 6 premiers mois de l'année à peu
près 100 millions d'euros alors depuis
le début septembre c'est totalement
spectaculaire on va dire qu'on est très
étonné ce qui veut dire que le spécial
prix on est passé à 20 centimes sur les
stations de Total énergie revivant les
10 centimes de plus les concurrents ne
nous ont pas suivi se traduisent par une
ruée des Français sur nos stations je le
dis à tel point que quand vous avez la
première semaine semaine plus 80% en
moyenne sur les stations effectivement
notre système de logistique n'est pas
fait pour approvisionner des stations
qui voient quasiment leur volume
augmenter ce niveau-là donc on a eu des
malheureusement il y avait des queues
importantes et puis on a eu des stations
en pénurie et donc on s'efforce de les
approvisionner alors j'y gagne rien
parce que là pour le coup à moins 20
centimes ça se traduit par un vrai coup
et donc je peux vous dire que le bilan
de l'opération puisque je reçois un
rapport hebdomadaire j'en suis à un coup
au bout de deux semaines de 71 millions
d'euros pour l'entreprise donc depuis le
début de l'année 171 millions d'euros si
je fais le calcul le chiffre que vous
indiquez Monsieur le Maire le ministre
le maire fin juillet de 500 millions
d'euros on devrait en être à peu près
puisque on a prévu de le continuer
pendant encore cette semaine là jusqu'à
la fin du mois d'octobre à 20 centimes
passés à 10 centimes donc l'estimation
par est forte alors au passage
d'ailleurs avec des phénomènes alors sur
au bilan de deux semaines je regardais
les chiffres on est en augmentation de
volume globalement de 30% parce que on
gagne sur sont les particuliers qui
viennent chez nous mais par contre les
professionnels peuvent nos stations
services en temps normal c'est pas les
particuliers qui viennent chez total
energy sauf chez Total Access qui est
moins cher c'est plutôt des
professionnels des des cartes des
entreprises professionnelles qui ont des
voitures professionnelles eux par contre
on perd parce qu'ils veulent pas faire
la queue donc ils viennent plus chez
nous ils vont ailleurs je sais pas où
ils vont mais il trouve que faire la
queue c'est trop long pour leur métier
voilà donc globalement au bout de deux
semaines on a gagné tout volumes
confondus voilà plus 30% par rapport à
l'année dernière sur les deux premières
semaines moi je veux dire c'est quelque
part je trouve que ça valide
l'initiative que nous avons prises on
sait dimanche je suis pas sûr que
j'aurais fait 20 centimes tout seul ce
qu'on était parti sur 10 centimes s'il
n'y avait pas eu un débat
avec le ministre de l'économie et le
débat qui était parti je pense de cette
assemblée donc je lui rends le fait je
trouve comme je lui ai dit récemment la
semaine dernière cette semaine que
finalement il nous a rendu service
puisque les Français voient concrètement
la traduction des super profites total
énergie directement à la pompe et ils en
profitent donc finalement c'est une
opération
doit contribuer à aider au pouvoir
d'achat il faut dire qu'elle s'est
cumulée je pense qu'il y a aussi le
phénomène que le 1er septembre non
seulement il y a eu les 20 centimes de
Total énergie il y avait 30 centimes de
l'État et donc ça fait 50 centimes donc
sur qui ont été affichés directement sur
les totems on voit les prix les Français
ont vu 2 € de venir 1 € 50 après
approximativement surtout que c'est une
période où le prix du pétrole a un peu
les cotations un peu baissé voilà donc
moi le bilan que j'en tire pour
l'instant c'est qu'en tout cas ça je le
savions en matière d'énergie le prix est
juste fondamental
prix est essentiel on atteint le pouvoir
la chasse un bien essentiel nous le
savons
la facture les gens doivent rouler
notamment amener les enfants à l'école
et travailler ils doivent se chauffer
etc et donc nous savons dans ce métier
là le prix est majeur pour pour les pour
les pour les consommateurs qui soient
d'ailleurs
individuel ou professionnel voilà je
peux vous dire où nous en sommes
à ce stade là
merci beaucoup d'ailleurs sur cette
question de l'aristourne j'en profite
pour signaler que pour ma part je
m'étonne parfois de voir certains vous
reprocher si je puis dire à la fois les
profits que vous réalisez et les gestes
que vous faites pour en restituer en
partie aux Français pour ma part en tout
cas
préoccuper justement par la protection
du pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens
j'incite plutôt vos concurrents à ou en
l'ensemble des grandes entreprises qui
sont confrontées à ces enjeux à réaliser
des opérations de la sorte je pense que
c'est dans l'intérêt général je voulais
vous interroger de nouveau sur la
question fiscale puisque dans les
discussions que nous avons c'est
évidemment une des options qui envisagée
et je tiens à préciser qu'elle est en
tout cas à mes yeux ni un totem ni un
tabou la fiscalité peut parfois être
efficace parfois elle peut être
contre-productive selon ces modalités et
selon ses circonstances et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je voulais vous
interroger sur les initiatives ou les
propositions qui ont été formulées par
la Commission européenne la semaine
dernière elle me paraissent digne d'être
examiné intéressante au moins double
titre le premier c'est que une
initiative strictement nationale à
entendre d'ailleurs les différents
intervenants qui ont pu être
redditionnés par notre mission et
vous-même dans votre propos introductif
serait borné à l'assiette nationale
c'est d'ailleurs je le signale aussi
pour les membres de l'émission ce que
même le LG Oxfam qu'on ne peut pas
soupçonner de complaisance envers les
multi-nationales à signaler dans le
rapport qu'elle a publié sur cette
question une initiative européenne
permettrait donc d'avoir une assiette
plus large puisqu'elle inclurait
l'ensemble des activités européennes
vous êtes d'ailleurs je crois mais vous
pourrez nous éclairer dessus au niveau
européen producteur et pas seulement
distributeur ou raffineur je pense
notamment à vos activités au Danemark ou
au Pays-Bas ensuite et c'est aussi un
élément qui est ressorti des différentes
auditions qu'on a pu mener une
initiative européenne permettrait de
limiter les effets négatifs sur
l'investissement ou sur l'attractivité
de notre pays puisque tous les acteurs
économiques dans tout le continent
seraient soumis si je puis dire au même
au même règle donc pour bien comprendre
et pour bien éclairer ce débat je
voulais savoir niveau européen si vous
pouviez nous dire quelle part d'ores et
déjà été restituées aux Etats vous avez
mentionné les impôts et les taxes en
France est-ce que vous disposez
d'éléments au niveau européen est-ce que
vous disposez d’ailleurs d'éléments
puisque ça permettrait aussi d'éclairer
le débat au-delà des impôts et des taxes
sur les sommes qui sont restituées aux
États européens au titre de vos
activités de producteur d'électricité on
sait par exemple que dans les énergies
renouvelables il existe d'ores et déjà
des dispositifs qui permettent de capter
les profits exceptionnels en France
quand le prix ne marchait est au-dessus
d'un prix fixé d'un prix de rachat les
opérateurs d'énergie restituent à l'état
les sommes considérées et donc
ceci étant dit avez-vous une estimation
de l'impact que ce soit d'ailleurs en
termes d'assiette ou de montant du
plafonnement des revenus des producteurs
d'électricité ainsi que de la
contribution solidarité exceptionnelle
sur les producteurs d'hydrocarbures tel
qu'elle a été proposée par la Commission
à la semaine dernière
bon d'abord vous avez dit beaucoup de
choses qui me paraissent correct dans le
débat notamment quand je pense bon on a
deux activités en Europe des activités
de producteur dans trois pays dans
l'Union européenne en fait nous
produisons dans 5 pays mais en Europe
mais trois qui sont le Danemark les
Pays-Bas et l'Italie
ou ne produisons du gaz ou du pétrole
nous sommes aussi producteurs au
Royaume-Uni et en Norvège mais ce n'est
pas dans l'Union européenne au passage
ces pays producteurs savoir que le taux
de fiscalité de la Norvège et de 78% sur
les activités de production de pétrole
et de gaz 78%, je paye en Norvège
d'impôt sur les bénéfices donc
c'est une fiscalité qui est relativement
élevée j'ai dit 49% de le groupe au
niveau mondial cette année 70% Norvège
et le Royaume-Uni comme ça se passe dans
beaucoup de pays producteurs je l'ai dit
qui a une fiscalité qui qu'il s'est
baisser quand le prix du pétrole baisse
parce qu'il cherche à maintenir les
investissements à remonter sa fiscalité
sur pour la production gazière et
pétrolière de 25% mais oui laxatif vous
n'avez pas entendu total énergie
d'ailleurs dire que c'est des bagnole
parce qu'on savait aussi que le
Royaume-Uni lui il a baissé quand le
prix du pétrole à m'embêté il cherche à
adapter leur fiscalité ce qu'on voit
d'un centre de pays producteurs mais
encore une fois il capte là il taxe la
rente pétrolière donc premier point en
matière de raffinage il me paraît
évident que l'Europe est le bon
périmètre pourquoi parce que les
produits de diesel essence il se moi je
ne les vends pas qu'en France mais
raffiri française alimente le marché
européen de même que nous avons des
raffineries en Belgique aux Pays-Bas et
en Allemagne elles ne sont pas que sur
le marché national donc une taxation des
raffineries françaises au détriment des
taxes des taxations des autres
raffineries m'obligera bien évidemment
c'est la mission de l'entreprise
d'optimiser pour le coup les productions
des diverses raffineries en fraction des
niveaux de taxation et deuxièmement
pourraient avoir une influence négative
sur les investissements des politiques
d'investissement construire amené à
faire donc donc je trouve que pour un
marché comme le raffinage ou encore une
fois on est dans un concurrence et
l'approvisionnement un sujet européen la
niveau européen est le plus adéquat bon
naturellement ça veut dire que quelque
part la base de taxation pour moi c'est
l'argile mais en tout cas et je
recommande d'ailleurs sur les projets de
taxation européenne il est très
important que le taux qui soit fixé soit
le même par tous les pays parce que
sinon si on crée une concurrence fiscale
entre les pays ma directrice fiscale et
puis mes équipes pour me dire ben écoute
peut-être qu'à ce moment-là le 60% que
vous invoquiez sera volontaire même si
c'est pas du tout l'objectif aujourd'hui
donc nous sommes un à partir du moment
où il y a un débat et le débat politique
est appartient
au leader politique de le faire mais de
le tenir sachant que fondamentalement
quand même je voudrais rappeler à
quelque chose d'important c'est que
notre pays par exemple souffre
aujourd'hui quand même d'une des
industrialisation et avec les
industrialisations qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire c'est qu'il y a des emplois plutôt
mieux rémunérés qui sont qui ont sont
quittés on veut réindustrialiser ce pays
tout ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui
écouter tout ce que vous faites au
Parlement est écouté par l'ensemble des
investisseurs pas seulement par Total
énergie qui peut avoir une taxe en plus
et est observé et est bien évidemment
dans un moment où pour être pour être
objectif l'Europe malheureusement grâce
du drame
ukrainien de cette guerre est soumise à
des tensions fortes des signaux qui
seraient défavorables à l'investissement
de la part des divers parlements
européens vont pas aider à convaincre
les investisseurs internationaux
européens à investir en Europe
c'est-à-dire ça il faut juste voir
qu'aujourd'hui c'est exactement pour moi
à une période au moment où l'Europe fait
face à une des difficultés je dirais
économique assez extraordinaire j'espère
qu'on en sortira rapidement de ce
conflit et de ses conséquences donc le
niveau européen est bon niveau de
concurrence alors pour répondre à vos
questions pour l'instant
si on regarde le texte européen il est
pas encore totalement stabilisé je dois
avouer que je suis un peu surpris que la
définition du profit ça soit dû prendre
la moyenne des trois dernières années et
dire qu'on aura de faire 20% de plus
parce que si je prends mon activité de
raffinage qui en gros je vous l'ai dit a
perdu de l'argent pendant les trois
dernières années ça va faire 0 + 20 % ça
va faire 0 ça veut dire que la base
c'est en gros j'ai juste le droit d'être
surtaxé pour la première année où je
fais des profits la moindre des choses
je l'ai dit au ministre le maire ce
serait à mon avis d'autoriser quand les
entreprises à récupérer une partie des
pertes qu'elles ont faites parce que
vous pourriez vous demander pourquoi
j'investis dans du raffinage français
puisque je suis j'investis pourquoi mais
j'investis parce que un fait beaucoup
d'emplois 5000 emplois de je sais que je
vais avoir des années difficiles mais
j'espère avoir des années positives et
donc si les années positives les profits
disparaissent bah je vois pas très bien
pourquoi je fais tout ça et en fait la
vérité c'est qu'on investit d'ailleurs
dans raffinage français parce qu'on
essaie d'apporter une réponse
industrielle assez perte on se contente
pas de les regarder qu'est-ce qu'on a
fait depuis maintenant au cours des 10
dernières années on transforme une
partie de nos RA en biorinerie de façon
à on réinvestit plutôt que de faire des
pertes dans des outils qui vont nous
permettre de faire des carburants
aériens durables dont on a besoin pour
la transition énergétique c'est ce qu'on
a fait sur la raffinerie de La Mède près
de Marseille c'est ce qu'on est en train
de faire à Grandpuits et c'est ce qu'on
continuera à faire dans les prochaines
années pourquoi parce que la demande la
demande demande de produire affinés on
va le Parlement européen a voter qu'à
partir de 2035 les seuls véhicules
commercialisés seront électriques et
bien c'est pas la peine de continuer
avec une de continuer à raffiner avec la
vraie difficulté majeure pour moi qui
est un sujet social parce que chacune de
ces rafferies c'est beaucoup de monde
non seulement dans l'entreprise totale
énergie mais les impacts locaux et donc
ce que nous cherchons à faire c'est pas
être arrêté les raffineries brutalement
c'est plutôt les reconvertir pour
essayer de profiter des savoir-faire et
des outils que nous avons pour produire
des énergies des carbonées de ton a
besoin donc voilà alors phénomène
renouvelable j'ai pas les chiffres
correspond à vos questions
je
de ce que je
oui en France il y a un mécanisme qui
d'ailleurs me paraît simple je vous dis
alors pour le coup les producteurs
renouvelables on demandait aux États
alors pour lancer leur projet d'avoir
une garantie de tarif l'État les assure
entre guillemets moi il me paraît normal
que ça soit l'état qui capture le
surplus de l'assurance je sais que mes
équipes ont dit c'est pas normal oui non
attendez là il faut savoir si vous
voulez pas si vous voulez garder les
surplus ben vous demandez pas la
garantie ce qui est d'ailleurs ce que
Total énergie va faire c'est notre
politique dans les énergies
renouvelables nous avons décidé que en
gros 70% de portefeuille serait couvert
parce qu'on appelle des contrats pour
différences ou des contrats garanties et
30%, on ne cherchera pas les garanties
on ira sur le marché libre on prendra le
risque d'avoir un prix d'électricité qui
ira vers le bas vers le haut comme on le
fait dans le pétrole et dans le gaz et
d'ailleurs la vraie vos décisions de
totale énergie si on doit apporter
quelque chose en ce métier des énergies
renouvelables et Christian des garbolies
c'est bien nous avons le bilan et la
capacité à accepter la variabilité et la
volatilité pour pouvoir investir sans
demander aux états des garanties de
revenus c'est pas du tout la philosophie
de l'entreprise et ses versa que nous
aurions de plus en plus donc il se
trouve que je n'ai pas la réponse mais
je pourrais vous la communiquer mais ce
rapporteur à la question précise tous
les pays n'ont pas ce mécanisme la
France là pas surtout les contrats
d'ailleurs sur les contrats plus récents
mais j'ai pas de j'ai pas du tout
d'objection voilà donc le débat européen
me paraît le bon cadre
je vous ai dit après la limite de ce bon
cadre c'est taxé de l'industrie
européenne ça veut dire quelque part qui
peut y avoir des réorientations
d'investissement qui sont faits au sein
de nos entreprises
mais en même temps voilà alors après la
définition donnée par l'Europe du
surprofit je vous ai expliqué pourquoi
elle me paraissait un peu un peu étrange
moi je souhaite qu'on puisse envisager
de reporter des pertes et puis d'autre
part qu'une partie du profit est
considérée comme normale parce que nous
dire que tout ce qu'on a et du surprofit
une vraie difficulté de l'exercice si tu
peux me permettre auxquelles votre
commission se confronte c'est que moi je
ne sais pas des fédération profit parce
que les gens nous disent vos profits ils
tombent du ciel non attendez je vais
quand même savoir que cette entreprise
il y a 100 000 personnes qui travaillent
depuis des années pour faire en sorte de
se retrouver dans une situation qui est
plus favorable mais avoir connu des
forums nous avons fait un pari en 2017
de devenir le numéro de mondial du gaz
naturel liquéfié NJ voulait vendre ses
actifs ou les avons rachetés aujourd'hui
le gaz naturel est kéfique tout le monde
découvre l'importance qu'il a dans la
cohésion du monde effectivement les
paris que nous avons fait et c'est des
milliards d'investissements qu'on a mis
dans gaz naturel et kevier avec des
rentabilités qui n'étaient pas
nécessairement celles qu'on voit
aujourd'hui il y a un bénéfice parce que
on avait fait des paris que la demande
de gaz naturel était fier augmenterait
pas seulement à cause de l'Europe ça
c'est une grande surprise on n'avait pas
du tout prévu que l'Europe devrait se
passer du gaz russe mais parce que c'est
parce que fondamentalement le gaz on le
vend en Asie et ça se permet de
substituer au charbon ce qui est une
façon de faire une transition
énergétique dans les pays asiatiques
donc c'est un pari qu'on a fait qui
marche aujourd'hui pareil je veux dire
le point mort de cette entreprise c'est
à dire le prix du baril qui nous
permettait d'être à l'équilibre en 2014
c'était après de 100 dollars du baril il
est à 25 dollars du baril c'est pas
arrivé par simplement parce que c'est
arrivé par un travail très important de
l'ensemble des équipes par des on a
changé la moitié de notre portefeuille
dans l'espace des 7 dernières années et
effectivement nous avons un point mort
c'est à dire que nous sommes
bénéficiaires au-dessus de 25 dollars du
baril le prix est remonté à 100 dollars
quand il était à 30 pendant le covid
quand j'ai vu des prix négatifs il est
tombé à 30 dollars et que l'entreprise a
fût des pertes j'ai vu personne et
encore une fois venir de dire que
c'était un problème d'ailleurs on a rien
demandé à personne on a traversé tout
cela donc dans cette affaire il est vrai
que les entreprises de matières
premières
qui sont fondamentalement dépendantes de
cours de marché internationaux je ne
maîtrise pas le prix du pétrole ni le
prix du gaz ce sont des marchés qui le
fixent et bien on accepte les prises de
risque importantes pour faire face à la
volatilité de ses prix et on ne peut le
faire que parce que d'ailleurs mais
prêts nécessaires à qui je seront
hommage on construit un leader mondial
qui a le bilan qui fait que nous pouvons
accepter de voir cette volatilité donc
aujourd'hui oui on profite du fait qu'on
a baissé le point mort l'entreprise à 25
dollars quand le baril est à 100 dollars
on a 75 dollars entre payer de marge on
voit que quand même que je vous l'ai dit
que la fiscalité des pays producteurs
nous reprend une partie de cette marge
additionnelle c'est les fiscalité de
rente et la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup on va maintenant prendre
les questions vous demandant de vous
cantonner à deux minutes par question
afin qu'on puisse en prendre le maximum
dans le temps qui nous est imparti oui
Marina Ferrari
autre présence à nos côtés aujourd'hui
alors vous avez déjà partiellement
répondu à certaines de mes
interrogations 4 temps sur les 1,6 à 1,9
milliards d'euros que vous payez par an
global en concernant les charges
sociales les impôts de production les
impôts sur les bénéfices en France
pourriez-vous nous mettre ces montants
en perspective avec l'activité le
chiffre d'affaire le résultat du groupe
en France deuxième point sur les 16
milliards d'euros d'investissement que
vous projetez de réaliser en 2022 vous
nous avez indiqué que 25% donc 4
milliards il reste sur la transition
énergétique et l'électricité
qu'en est-il donc quel montant seront
investis en France et qu'en est-il des
autres segments notamment sur le
raffinage vous avez déjà évoqué la
question j'ai vu par ailleurs dans vos
réponses que sur les 35% de vos
effectifs qui étaient situés en France
il y avait 89% des recrutements
aujourd'hui qui étaient des recrutements
de personnels étrangers donc la nature
des investissements à venir que vous
avez effleuré aura-t-elle un impact sur
la politique RH du groupe en matière de
recrutement et de localisation des
emplois en France j'ai cru entendre un
chiffre qui a été donné pendant votre
intervention on sait et vous l'avez
rappelé que l'activité est raffinage a
beaucoup souffert risque encore de
souffrir dans les années à venir les
investissements donc sur les segments
énergies renouvelables et l'électricité
pourrait-il préserver développer les
emplois au niveau national
enfin et notre collègue à miel
vous a questionné sur le sujet la
possibilité donc de mettre en oeuvre une
contribution au niveau européen donc
quel est votre position vous l'avez déjà
donné voilà mais quelle pourrait être
l'impact d'une telle taxation vous
l'avez dit mais vous avez peut-être des
pistes à approfondir sur la localisation
de vos activités et de vos
investissements dans le cadre de la mise
en oeuvre d'une telle taxation et puis
d'un point de vue plus philosophique
plus philosophique pardon je suis
d'accord avec vous on a aujourd'hui une
difficulté chers collègues à évaluer
clairement et à définir clairement la
notion de surprofit a-t-il des profits
indus ou pas quand on est dans une
activité de marché comme celle-ci c'est
très compliqué à établir voilà merci
bon chiffre d'affaires le chiffre
d'affaires une entreprise comme la nôtre
je grâce à vous je le connais
pardon je prends je réponds à vous les
gens prennent plusieurs mais c'était
plus facile pour moi de répondre
rapidement je vais essayer d'aller aussi
vite que vous pour non non mais vous me
dites que vous me calerez c'est tout je
veux répondre à toutes les questions
vous inquiétez pas
dans le chiffre d'affaires il y a des
notion que je connais pas dans une
entreprise comme la laine pourquoi parce
qu'en fait c'est fondament le chiffre
d'affaires dans une groupe pareil
intégré ces chiffres d'affaires de mes
récitations services en fait et je
trouve que j'ai 3000 stations de
services 3500 en France sur 16000 dans
le monde
station-service ou vente de mes
raffineries à des clients finaux chiffre
d'affaires dans les normes comptables et
donc il est de il est élevé comme malgré
tout il est de 200 milliards l'été
l'année dernière de 205 milliards il
sera sans doute plus élevé dans le monde
donc 43 milliards en France donc vous
voyez et pourquoi parce que mon aval mon
système de distribution et de raffinage
et surdimensionner français est plus
gros c'est l'histoire de l'entreprise on
est né en France et plus gros que ce que
j'ai mondialement dans ces métiers là
donc il est pas on peut en déduire ça
fait un cinquième de du chiffre
d'affaires et donc je dois à 5e des
profits ça marche pas comme ça parce
qu'encore une fois c'est pas les
activités où je gagne alors j'ai parlé
d'air du raffinage l'activité de
distribution vous le savez on le dit
souvent c'est un centime du litre alors
c'est assez facile on vend je crois
c'est 10 milliards de lit ça fait 100
millions d'euros par an c'est pas c'est
pas ça qui va faire c'est pas ça qui va
vous trouver c'est positif on ne perd
pas d'argent dans l'activité de
distribution c'est assez standard on a
une moyenne de 1 centime de litre net
une fois entre la marge brute et puis
les coûts fixes de cette activité
distribution c'est à dire de réseau et
de station-service en France c'est pas
c'est un sujet qui est bien connu donc
voilà alors la contribution à la France
du 1,5 de milliards par rapport à ça
dépend des années quand je payais quand
je payais que 6 milliards global en 2020
comme je vous l'ai dit 2 sur 6 ça
faisait beaucoup notamment parce que la
cotisation sociale française et
cotisations sociales français il faut le
savoir c'est un milliard cosciation
sociale patronale salariale c'est 400
millions de plus patronales c'est la
moitié des cotisations sociales
patronales que je paye dans le monde la
France le point de particularité
importante donc vraiment quand c'est à
peu près fixe montant là puisque il
dépend peu une bénéfice sont assez
faibles quand je leur ai apporté à 16
milliards ça fait moins et cette année
si c'est 30 milliards le 1 milliard 9
devrait un peu monter parce que je pense
qu'on payera un peu d'impôt sur les
bénéfices cette année compte tenu de la
situation que j'ai décrite bon voilà
donc c'est difficile de relier du
chiffre d'affaires et des résultats dans
la mécanique puisque dans chiffre
d'affaires il y a de l'intégration
d'accord
votre deuxième question était pardon
j'ai perdu le fil ah les investissements
alors les investissements en France je
savais que j'aurai la question du coup
je me regardais ça de près en dans le
métier du renouvelable des nouvelles
énergies en gros on a investi on a
investissé en 2019 400 millions on va
passer à 600 700 millions et on va viser
à peu près un milliard j'aurais pas vous
dire une bêtise un milliard un milliard
deux dans les prochaines années donc en
fait on aura doublé comme on le fait au
niveau du groupe donc la France suit que
la France suit dans les énergies
solaires et je l'espère demain un peu
d'éolien interne mais c'est compliqué
j'espère dans l'éolien offshore on est
prêt en faire plus
dans l'électricité dans le biogaz
également puisque on a on a une ambition
très forte on pense que le biogaz qui
est énergie locale qui est du gaz vert
marche complètement avec nos stratégie
gazières il y a un potentiel il faut
faire il faut faire en sorte de le
débloquer il y a d'ailleurs une assez
forte demande et puis on veut faire un
projet d'hydrogène vert sur la
raffinerie de La Mède donc on a tout un
ensemble de d'activités voilà donc en
gros l'ambition c'est que sur la France
alors sur la France je parle des
renouvelables les investissements en
France étaient dans son étaient en gros
d'un milliard un milliard deux ils vont
passer à un milliard 8 un demi milliards
parce qu'il se trouve que au-delà des
renouvelables on investit dans la
raffinerie grand puits et dans la
raffinerie Donges pour les transformer
grand puis en bioratinerie dont je pour
la moderniser puisqu'elle n'était pas
capable de faire de l'essence aux
spécifications européennes qu'elle
exporter sur l'Afrique on a décidé qu'il
fallait que tous les produits de
l'énergie soit aux normes européenne
voilà
dernière question l'Europe je crois que
j'avais répondu j'avais répondu je pense
sur l'Europe l'emploi
non mais l'emploi en gros l'emploi
français ben ces activités renouvelables
elles ont un avantage la question locale
donc chaque fois que je développe des
biogaz etc je crée de l'emploi local ça
se délocalise pas ça donc je vais dire
de ce point de vue là en fait la vérité
c'est que nous avons réinvesti la France
depuis 7 ans nous avions nous étions
passés 30 000 à 27 28000 on est on
repart vers 35000 parce que mais
pourquoi parce qu'on a décidé
profondément que puisqu'on voulait
investir dans une nouvelle énergie
l'électricité avant de vouloir aller le
faire un peu partout dans le monde on a
allait commencer à le faire chez nous
alors il y a un contexte concurrentiel
qui est ce qu'il est mais qu'après tout
c'était aussi un moyen d'apprendre dans
le marché français avant de vouloir
faire l'international donc on a
réinvesti sur la France et donc nous
effectifs suivent en France et donc oui
il y a moins d'emploi dans le raffinage
français mais il y a plus d'emplois que
je crée de nouveau dans ces nouvelles
énergies qui sont encore une fois
locales
merci alors nous avons quatre orateurs
oratrices qui sont inscrits madame Lebon
madame Dalloz madame pierrezbonne
monsieur Cazeneuve madame Marie Guy
monsieur Coquerel d'accord
j'ai deux cours sont Karine leboncoin
vous aviez tout à l'heure parlé de la
remise de 20 centimes proposées aux
consommateur mais cette remise elle
n'est pas appliquée à la Réunion où les
prix sont identiques dans les 160
stations services de Lille que ce
partage engine au la totale et Vito la
raison invoquée c'est d'éviter une
concurrence entre station et cette
remise n'est pas non plus appliquée
entre en Martinique et en Guadeloupe
pourtant fin juillet vous aviez annoncé
que cette remise s'appliquerait
également en outre-mer vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir j'imagine que les
territoires ultramarins connaissent une
situation de précarité et d'inflation
qui vient s'ajouter à une crise sociale
préexistante ce qui rend ses aides
particulièrement nécessaires donc
j'aurais souhaité avoir des
éclaircissements à ce sujet et d'autre
part j'aurais souhaité savoir quels sont
les investissements qui sont effectués
concernant la décarbonation dans les
outre-mer et plus particulièrement
évidemment à la Réunion tout en
maintenant l'emploi sur l'île je vous
remercie bon écoutez effectivement
l'intention totale énergie était
d'appliquer partout sur le territoire
français métropolitain et DOM-TOM la
même ristourne modélisation était unique
c'était l'engagement il se trouve comme
d'ailleurs nous l'avions vécu au mois de
mars lorsqu'on avait pris notre officiel
sur 10 centime que il y a eu à la
Réunion une je dirais une levée de
bouclier des indépendants sur la réunion
que c'est quand même un écosystème
relativement petit et je vais vous dire
comment ça s'est passé je veux être
transparent avec vous j'ai eu un débat
avec le ministre des tomes en charge de
l'outre-mer pour savoir si nous voulions
continuer et puis il y avait le préfet
localement le gouvernement nous a
demandé au contraire de de renoncer à
rabais comme c'était tout ça a été mis
en place en liaison avec le gouvernement
nous voulions pas être la cause d'un de
troubles à l'ordre public en la réunion
je pense que c'est parce qu'il y a donc
effectivement de ce point de vue là on a
pas décidé finalement comme on avait dû
y renoncer d'ailleurs au mois de mars ne
pas mettre en œuvre le rabais moi j'en
suis désolé pour les consommateurs
réunionnais mais en l'occurrence
nous voulions pas quelque part
déstabiliser cet écosystèmes réunionnais
et la recommandation encore une fois en
lisant été pouvoirs publics a été de ne
pas donner suite voilà moi je le
regrette à titre
total énergie mais je comprenais aussi
que il y a des impératifs qui peuvent
s'imposer à nous la Martinique et la
Guadeloupe c'est un peu plus compliqué
que ça il y a certaines stations je
crois on a réussi on l'a fait les plus
éloigné de la concurrence celle là aussi
encore une fois ce sont des tout petits
marchés ou il y avait une forme de je
dirais les esprits se sont échauffés
profondément voilà donc voilà ce que je
peux vous dire la vérité alors oui bien
sûr les territoires d'outre-mer nous
intéressent parce que ce sont des îles
et que là-dessus les énergies des
carbonées notamment l'énergie solaire
énergie éolienne ont des marchés enfin
ont un potentiel extrêmement important
donc on est on est actif on a plusieurs
fermes fermes solaires et on essaie de
développer des fermiers éoliennes à la
Réunion également il faut rendre
compatible de ce développement des
énergies renouvelables avec la
protection de la biodiversité dans ces
îles qui est aussi un impératif
important et donc c'est cela qui est
quelque part freine un peu notre
développement mais sachez que c'est
c'est haut dans notre agenda parce que
ce sont des marchés ou souvent
d'ailleurs on utilise du fioul et où on
peut trouver assez rapidement une gérer
du full qui coûte cher pour les
consommateurs donc sont des petits
marchés qui ont des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en énergie et donc
on peut trouver assez facilement faire
une énergie renouvelable rentable on a
également un projet important point de
vue là en Guyane une centrale solaire
qui viendrait en complément de la
centrale biomasse de la rivaux donc
l'outre-mer est un est un sujet qui est
prioritaire dans notre politique de
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
merci beaucoup Marie-Christine d'eloz
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président merci de vos réponses alors
vous avez dit vous avez précisé tout à
l'heure que vous n'aviez pas bénéficier
de d'aucune aide de l'État donc ça veut
dire palpge vous n'avez pas demandé de
PGE d'accord mais j'ai entendu aussi que
vous aviez la moitié de vos chercheurs
du groupe qui était en France est-ce que
et comme il y a un débat qui s'ouvre là
avec la commission des finances sur le
crédit pour recherche est-ce que vous
bénéficiez du crédit pour recherche ou
non voilà donc quelle proportion
première question deuxième question vous
avez fait état dans votre dans les
réponses que vous aviez fournies de
30000 salariés vous nous avez parlé tout
à l'heure de 35000 salariés non je sais
pas le delta est-ce que ça bouge autant
ou est-ce que
bon d'accord
très bien non mais est-ce que 5000 ça me
semblait une grosse variable
d'ajustement vous comprenez bien
d'accord
vous avez parlé du carburant vous avez
parlé du gaz qu'on est-il du fioul on en
est où parce que je suis député d'un
territoire très rural et dans notre dans
nos ruralité en France les gens se
chauffent au fioul domestique donc
quelle perspective comment et dernière
question quel est votre production
est-ce que l'ensemble de votre
production des raffineries et
commercialisée en France quel est le
delta entre production commercialisation
sur le territoire français voilà
géolocaliser en France
2000 sur 4000
et que quelque part ça fait partie et
notamment on a un centre très important
à Pau nous avons près de 3000 salariés
qui fait pas que la recherche mais qui
est un point et puis on a développé on
déploie on des voies en développement un
pôle sur sur sa clé mais donc on a
l'essentiel de notre savoir-faire
technologique et innovation et centrée
en France sur Pau un peu en région
lyonnaise à Solaize et maintenant on
essaie développer un pôle pour
contribuer à sa clé
voilà pour le CIR le fioul domestique
bon ça c'est un sujet alors aujourd'hui
pour être honnête
vos concitoyens il vaut mieux se
chauffer au fioul au gaz en ce moment ou
à l'électricité parce que la comparaison
des prix des trois énergies alors c'est
une grande surprise historiquement le
gaz a toujours été décodé par rapport au
pétrole c'est plus le cas moi j'ai
toujours appris dans cette entreprise
alors là à cause des conflits enfin des
conséquences du conflit
ukrainien sur la provision on a vu les
prix flambés mais aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
je vais vous dire il y a beaucoup
d'industriels ce qui est un vrai souci
qui sont en train de passer du gaz au
diesel il fonde sur les générateurs
diesel il y a beaucoup de très grandes
entreprises qui refusent chez le diesel
au passage ce sera pas très bon pour le
les émissions de CO2 parce que c'est
juste moins cher donc première question
alors malgré tout ça a monté je vais pas
vous dire le contraire et notamment ça
monte parce que malheureusement comme
j'ai de plus en plus on voit de plus en
plus industrielle acheter du diesel les
cotations du diesel européen montent et
entraîne quelque part le fioul passage
on sait que il y avait une conséquence
importante pour le continent pour
l'Europe de la décision de bannir les
produits pétroliers russes on l'avait
dit tout de suite c'est le diesel parce
que l'Europe est déficitaire en diesel
pourquoi je vous dis qu'on avait trop de
raffinerie mais il se trouve qu'on aura
fini européenne sont plutôt anciennes
elles datent d'après la deuxième guerre
mondiale et à l'époque on faisait
énormément d'essence donc on a designé
des raffiner européennes pour faire de
l'essence
dans l'intervalle il y a eu des
politiques notamment en France très
favorables au diesel qui ont fait qu'on
aille chercher à reconvertir mais c'est
pas si facile que ça reconfériez une
raffinerie du de l'essence au diesel et
donc on produit trop d'essence en Europe
et nous exportant des essences y compris
aux États-Unis
et on importe du diesel le fait que on
arrête on n'apportait pas mal de diesel
à peu près un sixième du diesel français
venait de Russie alors on va lui trouver
une autre solution nous on a du rap des
diesel en Arabie dans une raffinée en
Arabie il y a pas de problème pour
approvisionner le marché français c'est
le moment c'est un peu plus loin ça va
coûter un peu plus cher donc on est en
train de il y a des conséquences donc le
diesel le fioul souffre je dirais un peu
plus des cotations le point de vue là
pourquoi d'ailleurs c'est assez amusant
on envoie de l'essence aux États-Unis
qui ont pourtant beaucoup de raffineries
mais c'est qu'aux États-Unis il y a des
lois qui font qu'on ne peut pas
transporter des produits
raffinés du Golfe du Mexique vers New
York en utilisant autre chose qu'un
bateau pavillon américain il n'y a pas
assez de bateaux sous pavillon américain
donc c'est les Européens qui envoient de
l'essence aux États-Unis tout ça est un
peu pas été un peu mais on en profite
parce que les marches sont meilleures
qu'on les envoie là-bas voilà donc c'est
pas on n'a pas un système européen au
tard autonome je dirais dans le manière
du raffinage et
surcapacitaire en essence déficitaires
en diesel et donc pour vos concitoyens
j'ai pas beaucoup de solutions si ce
n'est que c'est vrai qu'il y a une
politique qui était lancée par le
gouvernement parce que je vous rappelle
que les chaudières refioul sont un des
sujets qui fait beaucoup de CO2
d'essayer de d'aider les Français à
passer à la chaudière au gaz ou à la
pompe à chaleur c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment avec les prix réciproques de
l'énergie cette opération est un peu
compliquée pour les convaincre on a mis
en place des aides pour le faire on
avait fait des aides les aides pour
essayer de on est à peu près ça va
passer vite on a 4000 clients par mois
donc à peu près 50 000 clients par an on
a un million de clients sur 3 millions
qui chauffent 3 millions de Français qui
chauffent au fioul nous on en a un
million et on en a à peu près 50 000
qu'on arrive à faire transiter du fioul
vers
gaz ou électricité c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui l'argumentaire est un peu
plus compliqué au-delà du coup d'acheter
des chaudières nouvelles etc donc voilà
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur poulailler pour pour votre
présence d'ailleurs et pour pour vos
réponses alors on vient un moment un
petit peu un petit peu particulier
inédit ou les crises se succèdent
s'écrit génère de l'inflation pour les
particuliers il se trouve qu'elle génère
aussi des bénéfices records pour
certaines entreprises dont la vôtre donc
beaucoup de Français et j'en fais partie
pensent légitime que ces entreprises
rendent du pouvoir d'achat aux Français
et aux Françaises qu'en pensez-vous et
si vous partagez cette proposition que
proposez-vous au-delà de la remise de 20
centimes par litre pendant quelques mois
à ce sujet d'ailleurs total semble être
le seul d'après vos concurrents à
pouvoir octroyer une telle remise en
mettre la clé sous la porte je
m'interroge donc sur votre marge quelle
est la marge de Total par litre et
vendez-vous à perte quand vous appliquez
une baisse de 20 centimes par litre ce
serait d'ailleurs intéressant d'avoir
les volumes vendus par département et je
pense notamment au fortement frontalier
le volume vendu septembre 2022 donc si
vous pouvez nous transmettre ça au mois
d'octobre par rapport à septembre 2021
autre question concernant vos filiales
je n'ai pas eu le temps de lire le
rapproche le rapport de 600 pages où mon
excuserait avez-vous des filiales
domiciliés en Irlande au Pays-Bas au
Luxembourg à Malte en Suisse et Chypre
et si oui quel est le niveau des prix de
transfert entre la France et c'est
filiales question sur l'arène parce que
c'est important vous êtes un fournisseur
alternatif d'électricité en France à ce
titre vous bénéficiez donc de mécanines
de la reine quel volume d'arène
avez-vous acheté en 2022 à EDF en euros
et quelle économie avez-vous réalisé
comparativement à l'achat que vous
auriez fait sur le marché
considérez-vous d'ailleurs normal que
vous puissiez bénéficier d'un relèvement
du volume d'arène entraînant un coup de
8,4 milliards pour pour EDF et donc pour
la collectivité alors que votre société
annonce un résultat sur le premier
trimestre 2022 de 10 milliards 4 soit
une augmentation par rapport au premier
semestre 2021 de
92% s'il déchiffre paru d'enchallenge
sont exactes et dernier point vous avez
donné des chiffres très précis
sur les dividendes versés en 2020-2021
et 2022 aux actionnaires français et
étrangers pouvaient vous nous donner ces
chiffres pas forcément aujourd'hui
j'entends bien et sur les crédits
d'impôts dont vous bénéficiez on a parlé
du CIR y a-t-il d'autres crédits
d'impôts dans vos bénéficierez je pense
au CIO par exemple je pense au mécénat
et peut-on avoir ces chiffres sur les
dernières années je vous remercie
autre question
je sais pas dans quel ordre je vais les
prendre les filières internationales bon
écoutez nous n'avons des filiales que si
nous avons une activité opérationnelle
on est totalement transparent il nous
reste dans les paradis fiscaux et on ne
se passe notre temps à les éliminer que
8 filiales au Bermude je crois de tête
donc derrière que deux que nous
contrôlons et si ce que nous contrôlons
pas mais notre politique depuis
maintenant 2015 a été d'éliminé toutes
ces filiales patiemment il y en avait
une trentaine il en reste 8 totalement
transparent dans les pays dit il y a une
question qui nous a été posée
considérée comme non coopératif par
l'Europe j'ai une fille à au Panama mais
il se trouve que j'ai une activité de
gaz naturel liquéfier au Panama où je
vends pour traverser le canal de Panama
j'ai eu une vraie activité industrielle
et puis j'en ai une au Fidji et il se
trouve que j'ai un réseau de
station-service au Fidji et vous pouvez
le vérifier il est là vous pouvez donc
voilà donc les deux filiales dans les
États non coopératifs existent parce
qu'il y a une activité industrielle et
je veux dire je suis extrêmement sur
cela je j'ai refusé tous les schémas de
vérifier fiscal peut le dire ou des
choix des gens m'expliquent que ça
serait plus optimisé genre d'écouter
d'accord mais c'est pas vraiment le
sujet tout ça c'est du troisième ordre
par contre la réputation de l'entreprise
est plus importante à mes yeux donc nous
sommes nous bénissons ces sujets-là et
le rapport vise à le faire les prix de
transfert entre les Pays-Bas et la
France et les prix internationaux encore
une fois c'est tout ça c'est très cool
enfin tout le système l'entreprise d'un
groupe international tous les transferts
fonctionnent il y a des contrats entre
mon raffinage néerlandais et mes
stations services en France qui sont
basées sur des contrats internationaux
c'est la seule façon de faire
fonctionner et pour moi c'est très
important d'apprécier la profitabilité
du divers business dans le groupe donc
tout ça c'est comme ça c'est codé et
encore une fois c'est je l'ai dit
contrôler par les diverses services
fiscaux et notamment le service français
vous m'avez posé des questions sur
les frontaliers on pourra vous donner
les chiffres je pense qu'il y a c'est à
peu près autant enfin c'est clair que
quand la France décide de faire 30
centimes de l'État et 20 centimes 50
centimes je trouve que j'étais à Évian
le 1er septembre au sommet
franco-allemand à Évian j'ai vu tout un
tas de voitures qui étaient pas toutes
françaises devant les stations surfers
moi ce que je pense malgré tout c'est
que c'est une contribution directe au
pouvoir d'achat je regrette pas de
l'avoir fait et je pense que c'est une
initiative qu'on avait commencé à
prendre qu'on nous a demandé d'amplifier
dans le cadre des débats que vous avez
et qui me paraît une façon rapide
surtout parce que je pense que le temps
de prélever une taxe c'est dans le
transformer en un impact sur les
français prend du temps donc on l'a on
l'a fait on y a contribué
500 millions d'euros c'est déjà beaucoup
d'argent pour une contribution
volontaire je veux dire c'est une
reconnaissance que oui on gagne de
l'argent alors le débat avec les
concurrents je dois oui je le comprends
pas d'abord ce qui est interdit en
France c'est la revente à perte
faudrait pas se tromper
les textes français la revente c'est pas
la vente et la revente deuxièmement moi
quand les concurrents des stations des
grandes surfaces font des prix d'achat
un euro de l'essence du litre avec des
bons d'achat dans leur magasin nous nous
plaignons pas ils pratiquent cela donc
je trouve recevoir des leçons de la part
d'un centre de concurrents dans les
grandes surfaces sur le fait que eux qui
prônent les défenseurs des pouvoirs
d'achat et dire que pour une fois qu'on
fait quelque chose qui est visible on va
être critiqué j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre la logique de tout ça donc
dans l'entreprise il est clair celui
très clair qui aujourd'hui finance les
500 millions d'euros mais c'est le
raffinage français qui gagnent de
l'argent aux bornes de la distribution
du réseau je vous donne les chiffres ne
gagne pas 500 millions mais ça c'est un
arbitrage que nous avons rendu au niveau
de l'entreprise qui est de dire bon bah
il y a une demande pouvoir d'achat on a
un surplus d'un côté on le rend de
l'autre côté voilà voilà comment ça
s'est passé ça me paraît assez logique
mais profondément les 500 millions
d'euros ils viennent des gains cette
année du raffinage français alors vous
pouvez me dire pourquoi voilà voilà
sinon je ne savais pas financer cette
opération
la reine alors la reine c'est vraiment
un mauvais débat un faux débat je
voudrais quand même expliquer comment ça
se passe concrètement et simplement nous
ne gardons rien chez Total énergie de la
reine rien la reine est un moyen en
l'occurrence que le gouvernement en
passant de santé à 120 utilisé pour
maîtriser le bouclier tarifaire et son
impact budgétaire au niveau de l'État
c'est un choix de l'État il se trouve
que eDF va devenir une entreprise à 100%
nationale entre EDF et l'État pourquoi
je dis ça comment ça se passe
si vous avez un volume de 110
tirawattheure d'arène la façon dont nous
calculons le tarif aux entreprises à qui
nous
tarifs l'électricité c'est qu'on va
considérer que sans littérawater c'est
50% de l'approvisionnement français pour
faire l'électricité pour ces entreprises
donc on prend 50 euros c'est 48 fois 50
%, ça vaut 25 euros donc on leur envoie
les 25 euros et puis les autres 50% on
va les acheter sur le marché qui est
aujourd'hui à 500 euros et donc ça fait
250 euros 250 euros plus 25 euros ça
fait 275 euros mais nous retranscrivons
intégralement l'arène dans les tarifs
aux entreprises je vous invite à venir
le contrôler c'est comme ça que ça se
passe quand vous décidez de passer de
110 tt
le 50% devient 55%, et si vous allez à
130 Wattara 60% donc je prendrai 50
euros x 55 % x 60 % 30 euros et j'irai
chercher sur le marché que les 40 euros
40% complémentaires donc il n'y a pas de
je suis totale énergie il y en a aucun
la façon dont ça se passe c'est que
c'est encore une fois un partage en fait
de la rente nucléaire historique que
l'État décide que les de faire en sorte
que l'ensemble des consommateurs
puissent en bénéficier pour moi dans
cette affaire ça a été un arbitrage de
l'État entre je prends je mets 21 en
plus qui vont être rendus par les
mécaniques que je viens d'écrire au
consommateur et notamment au
consommateurs des entreprises mais
également via les tervu et tout cette
mécanique parce que quand la creux
calcule son tarif régulé le fameux TRV
elle intègre le fait qu'il y a plus
d'arêtes et donc ça lui permet de et
donc quelque part comme le tarif est
bloqué d'ailleurs ça lui permet de que
la perte entre guillemets ou le gain
enfin ou l'argent qu'ils devront au
distributeur plus tard puisque pour
l'instant on fait des pertes sur cette
affaire je vais pas donner de chiffres
mais le
distribution d'électricité gaz dans le
pays et largement perdante en ce moment
c'est pas un métier d'ailleurs quand on
voit les petites entreprises
s'arrêter petit distribuer je peux le
comprendre vu ce qui se passe à
l'échelle d'une entreprise comme la
nôtre donc après comme toujours on fait
des pertes on fera des gains un jour il
faut accepter la volatilité de tout cela
voilà pour la reine les dividendes je
vous mettrai transparent on a
on a dépensé l'an dernier on a versé en
dernier
8,2 milliards de dollars je parle en
dollars puisque les comptes enfin ils
disent en euros mais le dividende cette
année on est pour l'instant sur une
trajectoire autour de 8 milliards
également du même montant je crois qu'on
augmente de 5% mais ça fait 100 millions
ça fait des divers d'états voilà voilà
un peu les charges les charges que nous
avons et c'est un chiffre qui est assez
stable depuis dire que l'entreprise n'a
pas baissé son dividendes depuis 30 ans
donc on le fait progresser lentement et
sûrement parce que on ne veut pas on
veut que ce dividende puisse résister
aux crises on a réussi à maintenir le
dividendes pendant le covid et donc on
évite de lui donner des à-coups
dividendes de base qui soit trop fort
parce qu'après quand le prix baisse on a
un souci de un souci de continuité
au passage la masse salariale de Total
est à peu près du même montant 9
milliards
monsieur le Président Madame la
directrice financière
leur merci pour votre rapport sur la
transparence fiscale même si bon pour
tout vous dire en matière de rapport de
performance et de transparence fiscale
moi je préfère ceux des organismes
indépendants mais à tout le moins il a
la vertu d'exister et on peut regretter
que avant 2019 nous n'ayons pas de
visibilité puisque je pars de votre
rapport où vous nous dites avant 2019
nos systèmes d'information ne nous
permettait pas de collecter le montant
des impôts et taxes autre que l'impôt
sur les sociétés sur les taxes de
production et les cotisations sociales
sont par exemple généralement intégrés
dans la masse salariale donc avant 2019
manifestement vous n'étiez pas en
capacité de connaître sur les 300
filiales dont vous disposez
un agrégat général à la fois des
chiffres d'affaires à la fois des impôts
payés et à la fois des choix que vous
pourriez faire de Terry au
territorialisation de des entreprises au
regard effectivement de ce que cette
mission met en lumière à savoir
l'inadéquation du système fiscal par
rapport aux pratiques de dumping fiscal
auxquelles ce livre les pays compris
européens entre eux et le besoin de
mieux d'Europe le deuxième élément que
je peux noter par rapport également
réponse que vous avez faites c'est le
défaut d'anticipation des entreprises de
l'énergie pétrolière et gaziaire ça ne
correspond pas que à vous puisque nous
avons auditionné pas mal d'entreprises
et maritime par rapport aux urgences
écologiques à la transition de l'outil
industriel vous nous dites 2019 moins de
1 milliard pour aller éventuellement
vers 4 milliards et votre rapport est
intitulé énergis life pour l'instant
c'est plutôt énergiste contenu de la
guerre en Ukraine alors maintenant je
vais partir de l'ensemble des réponses
aux questionnaires que vous avez pu
faire et vous poser quelques questions
pour mieux comprendre
au-delà de la du sujet où vous
additionnez manifestement la question de
l'imposition avec la question de
cotisations sociales pour moi il me
semble que les cotisations sociales
c'est plutôt des salaires différés pour
une couverture sociale que dont nous
bénéficions pour un système de
répartition auxquelles nous sommes très
attachés dont nous bénéficierons tous à
terme et donc je n'ai pas pour habitude
d'additionner à la fois les impôts avec
ce que une entreprise participe au terme
des cotisations sociales ou patronales
alors sur les différentes questions que
j'aurais à vous poser oui j'y vais c'est
vous nous dites que vous avez 300
filiales ce qui représenterait de 20 000
déclarations fiscales par an
priori il y a un bilan par an et donc
une déclaration fiscale donc de quelle
déclaration fiscale parlez-vous tout
simplement non non mais je pose des
questions après vous allez évidemment
apporter évidemment des réponses ma
deuxième question c'est concernant des
éléments ça a été déjà abordés sur le
fait qu'effectivement vous n'ayez pas ou
très peu de filiales dans des pays avec
qui soit non ou peu négatif ou de
paradis fiscaux vous dit détenez
néanmoins vous nous avez répondu une
entreprise au Panama détenu à 50% qui
est qui sont les 50 autres pour cent et
deuxième élément sur Fidji avec des
stations-service alors je suis très
surprise que sur les îles Fidji il y a
besoin de temps de station-service donc
combien de stations services sur ces
îles et quel est le chiffre d'affaires
de cette entreprise que vous détenez à
100% sur les sulfs
de 2 minutes
vous nous dites donc effectivement que
vous êtes votre imposition est liée aux
règles de la territorialité et ce qui
est bien normal puisque effectivement
c'est en fonction avec ses règles et
donc avez-vous fait le calcul de si tous
vos bénéfices étaient taxés en France
puisque les règles pourraient être celle
du siège social combien vous payer
d'impôts en France
oui attendez j'avais mon micro
la même chose je voulais répondu parce
qu'il y a un deuxième principe qui est
le principe de non double imposition
nous ne pouvons pas être taxés deux fois
sur le même bénéfice donc si nous sommes
taxés si c'est votre question donc je
réponds à votre question la même chose
j'ai répondu à vos questions la même
chose nous ferions exactement la même
chose pour par ailleurs vous pouvez
faire des projets d'attention non les si
vous en avez fait beaucoup pendant votre
questionnement donc je vais répondre sur
le même ton
l'impôt sur les sociétés les taxes à la
production bien évidemment nous les
connaissons simplement le rapport de
transparence fiscal veut agréger la
totalité des impôts payés localement et
nous n'avions pas besoin jusqu'à cette
décision que nous avons prise d'être
totalement transparent de remonter tous
ces chiffres par nos services
d'information on a fait un développement
informatique important pour permettre à
notre directrice fiscale d'établir ces
chiffres et par ailleurs de les faire
auditer par les commissaires aux comptes
parce que nous ne publions pas une
solution côté et nous ne publions pas
des chiffres sans qu'ils soient audité
alors effectivement on est remonté trois
ans en arrière 2019 ça prend du temps
parce que on dépose des déclarations
fiscales par exemple pour l'année 2021
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2022 il se
trouve que dans Fil Vert Pays certaines
en France et au mois de mai juin il y a
des pays où on dépose des déclarations
fiscales jusqu'à l'année suivante on ne
peut avoir les chiffres de 2021 qu'en
gros en mars 2023 pourquoi 20 000
déclarations mais parce que il y a une
multiplication d'impôts il y a pas que
l'impôt sur les sociétés d'ailleurs en
France vous avez votre questionnaire le
monde mais il y avait plusieurs lignes
donc on fait autant de déclarations
fiscales que d'impôts et autant que de
filiales qui sont considérés voilà
pourquoi il y a autant il y a 20 000
déclarations fiscales et que j'ai
effectivement des équipes importantes
vous m'avez demandé me dit
éventuellement 4 milliards non je ne
sais pas éventuellement 4 milliards que
j'investis dans les énergies renouvela
si je dis quelque chose devant vous je
n'ai pas pour habitude de mentir je dis
4 milliards parce que c'est au moins 4
milliards d'accord et vous le et nous le
reportons une société cotée à des
devoirs de transparence vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble de ces actionnaires et c'est
extrêmement important à nos yeux que
tout le monde des informations quand on
dit quelque chose c'est qu'on l'a fait
voilà pour les cas alors après bah les
Fidji ils ont le droit de rouler il y a
des stations services de toute l'énergie
en Fidji comme il y en a en
Nouvelle-Calédonie comme il y en a à
Tahiti il se trouve que historiquement
mon entreprise avait décidé de déployer
des réseaux de station-service dans le
Pacifique et donc vous pouvez les
vérifier que les stations services
existent si ça vous invite je vous
invite à venir au Fidji d'ailleurs c'est
assez sympathique pour les vacances
enfin à Panama je vous l'ai dit c'est
une activité de gaz naturel qui fait un
terminal de gaz naturel il me semble une
société américaine mais je pourrais
revérifier où nous effectivement nous
avons une action nous utilisons ce
terminal de gaz naturel pour fournir du
gaz naturel liquéfié à des centrales
électriques à Panama nous en fournissons
aussi à Puerto Rico et dans d'autres
îles des Caraïbes voilà voilà donc tout
ça une réalité physique et commerciale
que vous permet que je aucun problème
pour vous donner tous les éléments et
pour répondre à vos questionnements
merci monsieur le rapporteur merci
Monsieur prise en pouyani merci d'être
présent je profite de votre présence
pour saluer ce qui peut faire
l'efficacité est quand même la
performance de l'entreprise totale qui
est comme une grande entreprise
française depuis de longues années
dirigé par des patriotes je pense aux
souvenirs de Monsieur marjorie et se
faisant je pense que c'est une des
raisons de notre présence aujourd'hui en
nombre mais aussi de l'hypocrisie qui
parfois entoure cette commission nous
faisons une commission aujourd'hui pour
découvrir que la France ne produit pas
de gaz ne produit pas de produit pas
pardon de pétrole et nous ne demandons
pourquoi nous ne pouvons pas les taxer
comme la Norvège tu peux le faire et je
pense qu'il y a une grande
incompréhension première incompréhension
même si
les bénéfices que vous faites sont dans
des pays producteurs de gaz et de
pétrole les Français estiment et moi je
pense à juste raison qu'ils ont
participé à l'émergence de Total par
historiquement par Total n'existerait
pas et d'ailleurs nous sommes vous êtes
une grande compagnie pétrolière sans
réserve nationale domestique parce que
vous avez vu le soutien depuis presque
un siècle de l'État pour entreprendre
avec succès et vous-même avez fait votre
part du travail mais vous n'êtes
peut-être pas été seul dans cette
aventure et je pense que les Français
aujourd'hui c'est steam léser et on a
l'impression que vous ne participez pas
à la mesure des efforts qui vous ont
permis d'être cette grande d'être cette
grande compagnie je pense notamment
aussi à la formation du capital humain
vous avez dit vous facturez vous
refacturez 2 milliards d'euros de
services qui est bien je l'entends mais
vous-même vous êtes déçu d'un grand
corps de l'État et c'est à votre honneur
et et les capacités de Total et de ses
partenaires industriels à exploiter des
gisements de plus en plus difficile
d'ailleurs de plus en plus techniques de
la travers le monde sont liés aussi au
fait que vous vous êtes formés en France
par une excellente française vous êtes
protéger l'État français protège vos
brevets protège vos propriétés bon mal
gros parfois avec des difficultés qu'on
peut connaître dans d'autres avec la
guerre en Russie mais du meilleur
général vous n'êtes pas une société
seule dans la mondialisation rythme
société française et je pense que les
Français estiment que votre
participation n'est pas à la mesure de
ce que vous devez à la France et c'est
le sujet je pense de cette commission
par exemple sur le fioul
madame Daloz a dit à juste titre que nos
compatriotes dans les dans les zones
rurales et se sentait en grande
difficulté si vous venez avec moi
monsieur pouyanais expliqué à quelqu'un
qu'il faut qu'il change à chaudière
alors qu'il est au SMIC il n'y arrivera
pas donc notamment pourquoi est-ce que
vous ne mettez pas le rabais de 20
centimes que vous faites sur le
carburant pourquoi est-ce que vous les
mettez pas sur le fioul pour cet hiver
j'ai mes administrés nos administrés ici
c'est au-delà des étiquettes partisanes
qui font des crédits monsieur pouyanet
pour remplir leur qaful car vous savez
il y a eu 3 minutes 30 pour Madame Marie
grande difficulté grande difficulté pour
pour et c'est là sur les surcapacités en
Europe je suis désolé la dieselisation
du parc français a été fait par l'état
français certes mais vous le saviez donc
dire que les raffineries datent de la
seconde guerre mondiale il y a une
organisation industrielle qui n'est pas
pertinente pour pour la France et qui
n'est pas non plus souvent c'est à dire
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans les mains
de pays au style et il y a une question
de souveraineté nationale qui n'a pas
été anticipée par Total et l'État
français parce que c'est pour ça qu'on
tirement de ça et là maintenant nous
sommes bloqués et on voit bien que vous
maîtrisez l'entièreté de la chaîne
puisque vous pouvez faire cette cette
marche de 20 centimes que les
distributeurs ne peuvent pas faire donc
on voit bien que vous maîtrisez
l'entièreté de la chaîne de valeur de
production et que donc quand vous dites
que les bénéfices sont dans un lieu
c'est aussi lié à l'organisation de la
filière pétrolière en général pas
seulement total les trois loyers
de l'ensemble des participants merci
voilà vous voyez bien que les Français
ont des questions des réponses précises
à la participation à des forêts
je j'ai souvent répondu dans les
interviews que je revendiquais notre
nationalité française je suis conscient
que nous sommes sur le territoire
français avec dire on est une entreprise
assez originale puisqu'on est de loin la
seule entreprise dans les quatre cinq
plus grandes entreprises pétrolières
gazières menant d'énergie mondiale qui
n'avons pas de base nationale on avait
essentiellement historiquement le
gisement de lac ce qui fait d'ailleurs
que parmi les premiers gestes que j'ai
fait en tant que PDG j'ai considéré que
même si gisement le lac ne produit
quasiment plus de gaz nous avions une un
devoir vis-à-vis de ce territoire de
retrouver de l'industrialisation sur
l'acte et qu'on ne s'agissait pas de
dire je m'en vais et je pars donc on
travaille et ça je pense que c'est très
important à mes yeux et c'est vrai aussi
pour les sites ou historiquement on
avait des raffineries etc de faire en
sorte que une forme de responsabilité
territoriale d'une entreprise comme la
mienne vous avez des territoires où nous
sont implantés parce que autrement je
suis d'accord les gens nous voient ils
nous voient venir on a profité de la
production du gazola qui nous voient
disparaître on a dit non on va
s'attacher à redévelopper des activités
à l'acte qui vont être d'ailleurs du
biogaz qui vont être d'autres activités
ou aider dans son industriels à
s'implanter mais on a décidé de rester
impliqué là dedans donc je comprends
votre débat je pense que le meilleur
réponse à votre votre question c'est
qu'est-ce que je vais investir en France
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure sur les
énergies des carbonées la première
priorité de nos investissements ça va
être la France où je vais où j'investis
à peu près en ce moment un sixième de ce
que je fais dans les énergies carbonique
donc c'est un moyen pour moi d'être de
rendre entre guillemets si c'est ça
votre question au pays une partie de ce
qui nous a apporté on en est conscient
mais je pense également que notre
entreprise lorsqu'on se développe
mondialement on sert aussi vis-à-vis
d'autres entreprises françaises qui
viennent avec nous à l'international de
locomotive pour leur offrir d'autres
marchés donc les retombées d'une
entreprise comme Total énergie en termes
économique vont au-delà du simple
périmètre d'activité de Total énergie et
des impôts que nous pouvons payer et que
vous jugez indifférent donc voilà
vous savez quand vous avez c'est un
grand atout pour notre siège est en
France et dans le comité exécutif de
Total énergie il se trouve qu'il y a
aujourd'hui 5 6 français sur 8 la
nationalité des dirigeants influence le
choix de leur décision d'investissement
si je vous investissons comme le faisons
en ce moment pour remettre un moderniser
une raffinerie de Donges je suis pas
certain que mes concurrents américains
qui ont des raffineries en France
auraient pris la même décision donc il
faut faut voir aussi que ça a des tout
simplement parce que ces sujets là nous
les vivons directement au quotidien les
organisations représentatifs sont en
face de nous que nos 30 ou 35000
salariés français bon sens responsable
comme tous les salariés mais un peu plus
responsable parce qu'on est présent donc
c'est tout ça qui fait la dynamique
française une entreprise comme Total
énergie et je pense après j'entends
votre point et de ce point de vue là je
répète ce que j'ai dit je pense que
l'incitation du gouvernement a augmenté
notre rabais pour moi a été finalement
positif puisque les Français aujourd'hui
publicitent cette opération en venant
dans nos stations et voient concrètement
que ces profits se traduisent par et
finalement c'est ça qui les intéresse à
la fin voilà je suis pas sûr qu'il voit
les milliards partir dans le budget de
l'État voilà ce que je peux répondre à
votre questionnement sur la la le
caractère nation français de
l'entreprise dont nous sommes fiers et
qui est un atout vous savez si nous
avons gagné des contrats au Qatar c'est
parce qu'on est implanté au Qatar depuis
30 ans par nos propres activités mais
c'est aussi quelque part parce que dans
le jeu diplomatique qui se trouve que
Total est le seul pétrolier est gasier
mondial non anglo-saxon
sur le dessus j'ai pris votre question
je vais pas répondre aujourd'hui
non mais attendez ça là-dessus et
politique diesel en France quand dans
les années 95 il y a eu en gros un shift
les constructeurs automobiles vers le
diesel moi je n'ai pas dans le raffinage
c'est pas d'acheter total énergie à
l'époque j'étais dans l'état français
conseillé à Matignon il y avait
immédiatement les entreprises
pétrolières on dit attention on n'a pas
les outils et en 95 investir dans des
c'est des milliards qu'il fallait
investir pour on l'a fait sur certaines
on a investi dans une unité à Normandie
dans les années 2010 pour pouvoir faire
plus de diesel aujourd'hui je vous
signale que c'est un pari qui est un peu
perdant puisque 10 ans après les
consommations diesel en Europe diminuent
qu'on reparte pour des raisons et que
les constructeurs mobiles abandonnent le
diesel pour aller vers vers l'essence
donc tout ça c'est parce que c'est de
l'industrie lourde et que encore une
fois il y a des choix des décisions dont
parfois il y a un delta entre
les décisions qui vont être prises par
une entreprise comme la nôtre et des
politiques publiques qui peuvent varier
comme elles varie et c'est un problème
d'adéquation entre les deux
merci beaucoup comme leur tourne du coup
on va prendre les deux dernières
questions ensemble et ça vous permettra
de répondre et de conclure tout à la
fois celle de Charles de Courson qui
représente du coup je comprends Michel
castellini pour le groupe liotte et
celle du rapporteur général du budget
Cazeneuve
monsieur le Président première question
vous avez d'autres raffineries en Europe
vous n'avez pas simplement en France
est-ce qu'elles sont aussi déficitaires
que vous raffineries françaises deuxième
question pourquoi après 9 ans vous avez
accumulé 4 milliards de pertes sur vos
raffineries françaises pourquoi vous ne
les avez pas fermé
troisième question
si on appliquait au compte 2022
anticipés le dispositif du bénéfice
mondial consolidé
est-ce que la réponse que vous avez fait
tout à l'heure est-ce qu'elle est encore
valable ou pas
puisque vous savez à peu près où vous
allez 4e question
plutôt que de faire une taxation
exceptionnelle
ne faudrait-il pas plutôt poursuivre une
baisse raisonnable de quelques centimes
peut-être jusqu'à 10 centimes en 2023
et puis dernière question
est-ce que vous avez eu des recours sur
le caractère légal ou pas légal de cette
baisse de 20 centimes de la part de vos
concurrents vous avez parlé de réaction
de certains de vos concurrents mais y
a-t-il des contentieux en cours et puis
sur les effets pervers d'avoir 30
centimes de l'État et 20 centimes
pendant deux mois de Total puis 10
centimes et 10 centimes moi je suis de
l'Est
on subventionne en fait côté état les
Allemands et les Belges moi je ne suis
pas antiabète jouant anti anti-allemand
mais en fait il y a quelque chose
d'aberrant parce qu'il y a aucune
coordination sur les frontières donc les
gens viennent massivement chez nous à
tel point y compris chez moi je suis
Marnay certaines de vos stations sont
perpétuellement fermées
vous pouvez vérifier ce que je vous dis
puisque moi je m'approvisionne chez
Total sur la route de Chalon à
Vitry-le-François vous verrez elle est
tout le temps fermée ils sont en rupture
de stock il y a des fils il faut une
heure une heure et demie pour que ça
provisionner et donc il y a partout hors
service hors-service et puis après on a
totalement fermé
oui monsieur rapporteur monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup pour votre
présence d'abord moi je voudrais saluer
et l'entreprise et ses performances ça
lui les salariés total et ses dirigeants
si nous avions un champion français dans
chacun des secteurs notre périp notre
pays probablement se porterait beaucoup
mieux la question vous êtes sur une un
marché mondial vous êtes en compétition
avec des entreprises mondiales quelle
est votre performance relative en
matière justement de profitabilité par
rapport à vos compétiteurs au niveau
mondial deuxième question je suis assez
surpris qu'à distribution autant je
comprends la raffinerie on est
évidemment en compétition européenne
voire mondiale autant la distribution
assez locale pourquoi votre distribution
n'est pas rentable dans tous les cas à
des niveaux de rentabilité qui sont
extrêmement faibles
troisième élément est-ce que sur les
deux taxes qui sont envisagées au niveau
de contributions pardon au niveau
européen une fois sur les producteurs
d'électricité l'autre sur la partie
hydrocarbure est-ce que vous avez
regardé combien de filiales combien de
pays en Europe était concerné
potentiellement par cette contribution
quatrième point
est-ce que vous prévoyez pour 2023 et là
je rejoins peut-être la question
mon collègue de Courson est-ce que vous
envisagez de poursuivre votre effort de
20 centimes de manière ou du ou d'une
autre ou de participer à ce qu'on
appelle le fond vert qui serait une
participation
volontaire pour aider à la transition
énergétique et puis dernier point est-ce
que vous avez c'est évidemment la
question est impossible mais quelle
projection est-ce que vous avez une
projection du prix du baril l'année
prochaine parce que j'imagine que celui
qui sait est très riche mais voilà
est-ce que vous en quelle anticipation
macro vous faites de son évolution merci
monsieur le président
oui merci on va vous laisser la parole
juste pour dire à tout le monde que ça
sera le aussi l'intervention de
conclusion voilà pour qu'on essaie de
terminer dans les temps et je rajoute
une demande de précision qui va être
très courte
pas très bien compris tout à l'heure
votre réponse à la question sur les
marges avec la remise de 20 centimes
quelque sorte ma question est simple
est-ce que vous vous avez une marge
quand vous vendez le carburant avec la
remise de 20 centimes ou pas merci et je
rajoute aussi une toute petite question
précision que vous avez mentionné le
chiffre de 8 milliards pour les
dividendes que vous verseriez en 2022 en
précisant d'ailleurs que depuis 30 ans
ce montant des dividendes versés était à
peu près stable
pardon bah du coup vous pourrez vous
pourrez préciser donc ma question est
effectivement de savoir si dans la
hausse des profits que vous prévoyez
pour l'année 2022 au niveau mondial et
c'est à dire qu'une grande partie serait
ou bien provisionnée ou bien
alimenterait les investissements ou bien
alimenterait votre politique salariale
ou différent ou différents gestes je
peux vous dire d'abord je descendais
être l'entreprise
lorsqu'on a traversé le covid je vous ai
dit qu'on n'a pas demandé d'être mais on
a augmenté l'endettement de l'entreprise
on a un bilan nous aurons une dette
quasi nulle à la fin de l'année la
priorité dans ces métiers là compte une
volatilité extrême des prix c'est la
meilleure protection de l'entreprise et
d'avoir un bilan le plus désendetté
possible donc en ce moment c'est à dire
une chance quelque part on va désormais
une entreprise pour le point donc voilà
alors je vais revenir dans les vesti
dans l'ordre alors Monsieur de corchon
vos questions il se trouve que mes
raffineries d'envers en Belgique des
élans dans Hollande et de loïna en
Allemagne fonctionne avec des taux de
fonctionnement mieux et gagne de
l'argent
elles sont plus modernes je vais vous le
dire aussi ça c'est la réalité des
outils mais on gagnait de l'argent au
cours des dernières années ce qui fait
d'ailleurs je réponds à une question de
Monsieur Cazeneuve où est-ce que on va
payer la contribution européenne
Allemagne Pays-Bas Belgique France
Danemark Italie les six pays ou si en
l'état du texte alors après je sais pas
s'il va vous dire mais l'état du texte
c'est les pays où nous produisons où
nous raffinons voilà les 6 pays où nous
serons amenés dans l'Union européenne à
payer cette contribution
pourquoi je continue à investir c'est de
parce que quelque part d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que je vais remporter répondu en
vous disant qu'on avait décidé de
commencer à transformer des raffineries
en biographie
aux pertes oui mais vous savez quand on
investissait pour 400 millions d'euros
sur la raie de La Mède c'était à peu
près 4 années de perte donc j'ai dit il
faut le faire maintenant cette
raffinerie est à l'équilibre elle fait
par ailleurs un biocarburant du biodiel
dont on a besoin pour la transition
énergétique grand puis c'est pareil donc
on a le calcul simplement c'est des
opérations massives qui demande beaucoup
d'efforts de compréhension parce qu'à
chaque fois il faut réinvestir il y a
des enjeux sociaux nous ne voulons pas
j'ai un impératif depuis PDG je ne
licencie personne en France et donc
toute opération de reconversion doit se
traduire par des plans qui font en sorte
qu'on retrouve des emplois à tout le
monde je ne sais pas le faire sur toutes
les raffineries en même temps et par
ailleurs il se trouve que j'ai quand
même besoin de quelques raffineries
parce qu'aujourd'hui ce qui fait rouler
les Français et les Européens c'est
quand même de l'essence et donc on a
besoin de garder un équilibre et c'est
tout le débat de la transition
énergétique c'est combien je garde
d'outils raffinage et qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va garder les plus
forts les plateformes les plus
importantes en France et Normandie
notamment mais on investit aussi à
Donges pour la moderniser c'est sans
doute envers en Belgique c'est sans
doute loïna même si loïna en Allemagne
compte ce qui se passe qui est au bout
du fameux tuyau russe ça la question de
comment tout ça va fonctionner et est
devenu très compliqué avec le conflit
voilà un peu les points
non BMC je pense qu'on est pendant le MC
je vous l'ai expliqué c'est une
mécanique en fait où on prenait la base
mondiale on déduisait les impôts la
vérité c'est que c'était pour Total
énergie une assurance anti catastrophe
dans un pays anti nationalisation si
tout d'un coup ce qui se passe
d'ailleurs en Russie je suis amené à
arrêter les actifs j'ai pas je sais pas
avoir des pertes fiscales russes si j'ai
un bénéfice mondial consolidé je
pourrais imputer potentiellement des
pertes russes sur mon éponéphine mondial
sans avoir de fiscalité aussi donc c'est
plus c'était plus vu par le management
de l'époque comme une espèce de
d'assurance anti-nationalisation anti
catastrophe que réellement d'optimum
fiscal donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
quand les débat à l'époque au Parlement
qui a conduit à dire où on arrête il y a
eu des rapports etc l'entreprise n'avait
pas n'était pas
c'était naturellement inscrit au
bénéfice mondial consolidé et pris
l'option parce qu'il y avait une espèce
de d'assurance n'hésitez pas un problème
d'optimum fiscal en ce temps que tel les
impôts donc la réponse pour moi à votre
question et non ma directrice fiscale
contrôlera mais je pars se sont contrôle
c'est ce que j'ai compris en tout cas du
mécanisme
la continuité de 2023 va quand même
dépendre du niveau des taxations que
vous allez tous décider je peux me
permettre je suis bien que mais on peut
pas on a fait ce mouvement volontaire et
comme je m'étais exprimé d'ailleurs
publiquement en esprit non seulement les
clients nous entendraient mais
l'ensemble
des représentations politiques
parlementaires nous engendrer moi
j'attends de voir ce qui va sortir aussi
du niveau européen et quel combien va
représenter l'effort européen il
représentera sans doute enfin il sera
au-delà du milliard d'euros moi
j'attends de voir exactement quelle va
être la base et comment vont être taxé
ces profits avant de décider si la
partie volontaire continue ou non je
vais
recours légal non il n'y a pas de
recours légal mais honnêtement il y a
pas de base légale tout le monde se
plaint mais nous ne sommes pas en
position dominante nous avons 3400
stations sur 12000 11000 on a c'est pas
une position dedans il y a pas d'habits
de position dominante il y a pas de
revente à perte et par ailleurs je peux
vous démontrer moi je me suis jamais
plaint quand un centre de concurrence je
sais pas si c'était leur nom font des
opérations de promotion sur l'essence
pour vendre plus dans leur supermarché
c'est l'intégration horizontale de faire
l'intégration verticale voilà donc et je
peux vous dire que cette question la
vérité c'est que quand j'ai eu le débat
avec mises économie j'ai exactement posé
la question en disant et somme nous
certains que de points de vue
concurrentiels et les Bercy nous a
rassuré sur ce point comme mes juristes
d'ailleurs voilà donc il y a pas de
recours il y a eu une demande amiable de
la part d'un de mes concurrents et
partenaires de lui faire le même rabais
malheureusement ça c'était là on
changeait s'il fallait que je suis
vançonne toutes les 11 sessions de
services de France ça c'est plus 500
millions d'euros ça aurait été de
milliards et ça j'étais pas prêt à le
faire pour être honnête
voilà et
la Marne j'ai noté donc vous aurez de
l'essence dans votre station service
monsieur de Courson je vais m'en occuper
des retours au bureau cet après-midi
mais je sais que on a un souci c'est que
honnêtement le système de logistique est
pas fait pour faire appel à tel niveau
on a été dépassé franchement par la et
je suis c'est une vraie leçon de voir
comment les signaux un petit peu plus
font déplacer effectivement les
concurrents non pas suivi au passage
certains concurrents il y a pas que nous
qui raffinons du pétrole en France
et qu'ils ont donc il y en a d'autres
nous faisons que la moitié du raffinage
français aujourd'hui à peu près
performance relative je sais
je compte total énergie est une
entreprise qui fonctionne bien nous
avons parmi les 5 plus grands pétroliers
privés mondiaux qui sont des nains nous
avons aujourd'hui je dirais nous sommes
le numéro 4 en termes de génération de
cash flow on a profitabilité était un
peu supérieur à celle des autres
aujourd'hui mais grosso modo on fait en
tout cas on tient notre rang la vraie
différence c'est que les concurrents
américains distribuent beaucoup plus
d'argent et leurs actionnaires que nous
beaucoup plus après 45% de leur cash
flow quand nous on est plutôt à 30 35%,
et ça fait que les cours de bourse des
entreprises américaines pétrolières sont
à peu près une fois et demi plus élevé
que les entreprises pétrolières
européennes voilà donc il y a un retour
il y a une culture de côté
contrepartie eux les États ou la Banque
centrale européenne parce qu'aujourd'hui
notre peur quand vous avez des appels de
marge de plusieurs milliards dans une
soirée c'est que si la contrepartie fait
défaut les milliards disparaissent et
donc le donc aujourd'hui le marché ne
fonctionne pas par manque de liquidité
et par ailleurs il est parti dans un
espace assez nouveau marché de
l'électricité ne prêche plus du tout la
centrale à gaz marginale comme nous on
voulait dire c'est plus ça il est en
train de se mettre à un niveau qui est
combien un industriel est prêt à payer
d'électricité pour continuer à faire
tourner son usine sachant que certains
vont arrêter donc on est au-delà de
toute conditionnalités donc il y a un
problème de liquidité et et ma
recommandation vivement j'en ai fait
part voir public c'est que il faut
donner des bonnes nouvelles à ce marché
la Bonne Nouvelle annoncé par le
président de la coopération
franco-allemande je vous donnerai du gaz
vous n'aurez l'électricité c'est très
important il est très important que le
marché est le sentiment que la
solidarité européenne va fonctionner et
que dans cette affaire il faut prendre
en main toutes les économies qu'on a
fait dire qu'on va y arriver plutôt que
de dire qu'on va abonnés arrêtez des
arrêtés c'est des messages négatifs ça
fait monter tous les prix il faut au
contraire se dire oui on doit faire des
économies collectives l'énergie nous
allons lancer une campagne d'ailleurs de
communication et on va d'ailleurs mettre
un tarification pour que les gens les
consomment nos clients dans
l'électricité qui économiseront plus de
5 % par rapport à la consommation de
l'année dernière on va leur renvoyer de
l'argent on va leur rendre de l'argent
on va les inciter à économiser de façon
positive il faut que cette question
d'économie d'énergie soit vu
positivement parce que c'est ça la bonne
réponse sinon c'est marché aujourd'hui
honnêtement sont pas très raisonnables
bon vous m'avez pas posé une question
bizarrement sur les rachats d'actions
puisque dans le débat qu'est-ce que vous
fait des rations je vais vous dire en
fait une entreprise comme l'anneau je
veux dire ce qui se passe depuis 2015 on
a eu des temps assez compliqués quand le
prix s'est effondré nous avons dû
utiliser nous avons émis des actions
j'ai émis près de 400 millions d'actions
c'est après 15% du capital parce que
pour faire des opérations je ne pouvais
pas les payer avec du cash et de la
dette
on rachète des actions depuis 2018 et je
n'en ai racheté des 400 millions que 250
millions et en fait le rachat d'action
c'est racheter les émissions les actions
que nous avons émises à un moment où la
situation était difficile pour pour que
l'entreprise consiste continuer à ses
développer de façon et nous avons diluer
nos actionnaires de façon à arracher les
gens voilà ce que nous faisons en ce
moment donc oui nous rachetons des
actions mais j'en ai encore racheté ne
serait-ce que pour revenir au même
niveau d'équilibre c'est ça enfin les
gens voient les rachats d'actions comme
des moyens un peu étranges mais en fait
pour moi on nous avons utilisé les
actions pour faire par exemple une
opération de rachat de la compagnie
danoise merks qui se trouve révèle être
une excellente opération par des actions
et bien maintenant les rachète les temps
meilleurs donc elle est tendue on
utilise des actions et on dilue aux
actionnaires il y a des temps meilleurs
où on élimine les actions qu'on a émises
voilà un peu comment on pilote et quelle
est la philosophie d'ailleurs c'est
rachat d'action au sein de Total énergie
sur la marge la marge non je vous ai dit
je vous ai dit la ne perd pas l'argent
elle gagne 100 millions d'euros en
France un centime de litre en moyenne
après coup fixe donc je vous ai
effectivement quand je consacre 500
millions mais ça vient raffinage voilà
mais encore une fois
voilà non
c'est un transfert des surplus du
raffinage qui finance l'opération des
rabbé mais c'est bien l'esprit dans
lequel vous êtes puisque vous nous dites
vous faites des surprofis sur le
raffinage on est en train de les
utiliser pour financer l'opération des
rabais donc dans chaque litre vendu avec
la remise vous perdez de l'argent à ce
niveau là on perd de l'argent
c'est pour ça que je vous ai parlé d'un
coup tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup donc nos concluons nos
travaux pour la journée nous nous
retrouvons mardi prochain pour la suite
de ces auditions